[Musique]
Béatrice Bruger, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succintement ?
Oui, d'abord, merci. Merci de me
recevoir. Donc je m'appelle Béatrice
Bruger. Euh je Qu'est-ce que je peux
vous dire ? Mon âge non, j'y tiens pas.
En fait, si j'ai 50 ans, euh je suis
magistrat
euh depuis à peu près 20 ans. Euh voilà,
j'étais pas d'ailleurs destinée
particulièrement à devenir magistrat. Je
suis plutôt pénaliste. Euh je suis même
que pénaliste et j'ai pris une
orientation il y a quelques années un
peu particulière que j'aurais jamais
imaginé d'ailleurs puisque je fais du
syndicalisme et je m'occupe d'un d'un
syndicat de de magistrat qui s'appelle
Unité Magistrat et qui est raccroché à
une confédération qui s'appelle FO.
Par ailleurs, bah je suis une
perpétuelle étudiante
puisque j'ai repris des études l'année
dernière au Knam et cette année, je suis
auditrice civile à l'école de guerre
qui était anciennement collège
interarmée de défense.
Tout à fait, tout à fait. Voilà.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler un
petit peu de votre profession ? Pourquoi
vous avez fait ça ? Pourquoi
vice-procureur ? Est-ce que pourquoi
vous avez abordé les questions de
terrorisme d'ailleurs ?
Alors pourquoi magistrat ? Je je vous
dis tout de suite, j'ai pas totalement
la réponse. C'est c'est un petit peu
parfois même pour moi un étonnement
puisque je pas fait d'études de droit.
Donc c'est c'est un parcours un petit
peu plus hors sentier.
Ceci dit, j'ai toujours été attirée, et
ça c'est mes études littéraires, à la
fois par l'architecture du lieu,
le pénal, ça c'est sûr, le côté tragique
peut-être aussi du pénal et puis par la
justice qui me semble quelque chose
d'extrêmement central. Par ailleurs
euh donc le le pénal me semblait être la
matière la plus intéressante parce que
c'est l'humain, on est vraiment on n'est
pas trop sur la technicité. On est
vraiment sur sur l'humain et j'ai eu la
chance puisque j'ai commencé dans le
nord de la France euh où j'ai été nommé
en effet au parquet comme substitut
général à la cour d'appel de doué. J'ai
eu la chance très rapidement euh de
faire ce que je ce qui m'a toujours
intéressé, je crois en tout cas sur le
plan de l'imaginaire euh d'être au cours
d'assise. Voilà, parce que les cours
d'assise, c'est une justice de luxe, je
crois, où on a le temps, on a le temps
et on a surtout tout ce travail de
procès. On est dans une situation
aujourd'hui où on va de moins en moins à
l'audience et la justice se rend de
moins en moins dans les prêtoirs.
D'ailleurs, les avocats s'en plaignent.
C'est un véritable un véritable sujet de
réflexion. Voilà. Donc j'ai commencé sur
les cours d'assise et puis je suis
restée restée sur le pénal
essentiellement mais j'ai fait un petit
crochet par la chancellerie puisque dans
mon parcours, je me suis occupée aussi
de ce qu'on appelle la coopération
internationale pour le ministère de la
justice où j'ai pu voyager si et là euh
pour voir un petit peu aussi d'autres
façons de faire euh excusez-moi
notamment dans les pays de l'Est et je
faisais de la coopération de la
coopération
Je vais je vais vous poser une question
très brutale d'un coup. Pourquoi on voit
pas plus de politique en prison ?
Pourquoi on voit pas plus de politique
en prison ? Euh
alors, je serais incapable de vous dire
d'abord s'il y en a beaucoup.
Objectivement, c'est une question que je
me suis jamais posée. Euh
[Musique]
je sais pas s'il faudrait faire un un un
un ratio, j'allais dire du nombre de
condamnations des hommes politiques et
et du fait qu'ils sont en prison. Parce
que on peut être condamné et ne pas
aller en prison, hein. Déjà, c'est deux
choses très différentes. Euh
comme souvent avec les politiques, non ?
comme souvent avec les politiques, je ne
sais pas euh je je sais pas si c'est un
c'est un but de dire euh voilà les
politiques doivent être en prison. Euh
vous voyez, c'est pas c'est pas comme ça
qu'on aborde les le sujet. On pourrait
être condamné et euh la prison n'est pas
obligatoirement non plus euh la
référence ultime de la sanction.
D'ailleurs aujourd'hui, on s'aperçoit
que peut-être la pire des sanctions dans
notre société qui est très médiatique,
c'est d'être mis au pilorie.
C'est-à-dire, c'est déjà euh cette
espèce de de
condamnation par les médias qui pour un
homme politique peut-être pire, j'allais
dire que que même le fait d'être en
prison. Mais je saurais pas je saurais
pas répondre à cette question et à la
fois c'est pas obligatoirement non plus
un objectif si vous voulez pour pour les
magistrats. Est-ce que vous trouvez
qu'il y a une justice à à 25 vitesses en
France que vous c'est c'est quoi le
vieilladage ? et que vous soyez faible
ou puissant.
Comment ça se termine ce vieillage ?
Oui. Que vous soyez faible ou puissant ?
Alors, c'est vous serez jugé selon en
fait votre catégorie sociale en en
réalité. Si vous êtes faible et ben vous
avez plus de chance d'être sévèrement
puni. Si vous êtes puissant, vous avez
plus de chance d'échapper à la justice.
La fontaine, les femmes de la fontaine
déjà aussi le rappeler avec beaucoup
d'intelligence humaine. Euh c'est vrai,
c'est vrai que c'est un combat permanent
en réalité l'égalité des droits mais
l'égalité aussi du traitement parce que
ça va dans les deux sens. C'est-à-dire
que on a eu tout ce tout ce chemin
depuis la Révolution française
d'abolition des privilèges euh et
d'égalité
pour avoir les mêmes droits. Mais en
revanche, on s'est sans doute moins
intéressé aussi sur l'égalité de
traitement euh parce que c'est pas c'est
pas le tout de dire on a des droits,
faut-il encore qu'il soit exercé
réellement dans cette égalité. Et c'est
un travail permanent. C'est comme la
liberté si vous voulez. C'est un travail
vivant, c'està-dire que c'est jamais
acquis cette égalité. C'est c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut toujours
remettre en question et sur lequel il
faut toujours se battre. Et on a quand
même quand on regarde le chemin
parcouru,
on arrive quand même sur une société,
j'allais dire où la justice tend à être
de plus en plus égalitaire. La réalité
c'est queon arrive pas mais on a ce
mouvement. Mais ce mouvement est souvent
accompagné aussi de mouvements arrière,
c'est-à-dire c'est un pas en avant et
puis deux pas en arrière. C'est-à-dire
que c'est un travail permanent. Et euh
la dernière réforme par exemple euh
puisque c'est sur le politique que vous
avez commencé, la dernière réforme qui
concerne la justice où on aimerait
justement abolir ces ces différences de
traitement euh c'était euh la
proposition de supprimer la Cour de
justice de la République. La Cour de
justice de la République, c'est une cour
spécifique pour les hommes politiques
qui sont en fonction et c'est une cour
justement qui est mixte. C'est-à-dire
que il n'y a pas que des magistrats, il
y a aussi des parlementaires. Et c'est
une façon de dire "Bon, vous ne pouvez
pas être jugé comme tout le monde parce
que justement votre statut politique
fait que vous avez une autre façon
d'être jugé."
Ce ce projet
qui avait été d'ailleurs annoncé en
grande pompe par notre président
Emmanuel Macron euh me semble abandonné
de toute façon comme tout ce qui était
dans dans la réforme constitutionnelle
dont on sait pas encore aujourd'hui si
elle verra elle verra le jour.
On voit euh nos politiques se faire
condamner. Souvent, c'est autour de 2
ans et en fait, ils vont pas en prison,
ils ont une peine aménagée,
bracelet électronique ou des petites
choses comme ça. Est-ce que vous trouvez
ça normal ce ce traitement presque
préférentiel ? Alors, c'est pas un
traitement préférentiel parce qu'en
fait, c'est le traitement de tout le
monde. C'est-à-dire que euh il faut
jamais oublier, et ça c'est c'est un
vrai sujet euh euh polémique
pratiquement. On dit toujours les
magistrats finalement, ils sont assez
laxistes, euh ils prononcent des peines,
ils les applient pas. Les magistrats,
ils prononcent euh des peines euh
et ils appliquent les lois. Et les lois,
elles sont pas faites par les
magistrats, c'est ce qu'on oublie
souvent. Elles sont faites par les
politiques et oui et et tous les
politiques, on va pas reprendre toute la
politique, toutes les lois qui ont été
faites sur l'exécution des peines. Et si
on regarde la courbe, toutes les lois
qui ont été votées, toute majorité
confondue puisqu'on a commencé avec
Rachid Adati par exemple sur
l'aménagement de peine mais bien avant
et cetera, ont plutôt eu tendance et de
façon très claire à mettre en place un
droit à l'aménagement de peine et ça
c'est pas propre pour les hommes
politiques puisqueen fait c'est pour
tous les citoyens. Ce qui fait que
toutes les peines que nous on prononce
l'ont prononcé jusqu'à 2 ans avant la
dernière réforme qui est passée il y a
quelques mois avait un droit
aménagement. Euh c'est-à-dire que si on
remplissait certaines conditions, cette
peine, elle pouvait être aménagée. Donc
c'est pas propre aux hommes politiques,
mais ce qui est propre aux hommes
politiques, c'est que c'est eux qui font
voter ces lois et c'est eux. Alors, on
pourrait tout à fait penser que ils le
font parce que ça les intéresse. Je je
n'en sais rien. Mais ce qui est sûr,
c'est que nous, on est enferré ou
enfermé, si vous voulez, dans un cadre
législatif. Certes, on a une marge de
manœuvre, mais pas tant que ça. Pas tant
que ça. C'est-à-dire que il y a quand
même aussi des critères légaux. On peut
pas faire exactement ce que l'on veut.
Et la politique aujourd'hui, de toute
façon pour tous les citoyens, c'est
d'incarcérer le moins possible.
C'est-à-dire que de ne plus faire de la
prison une peine de référence.
Quand on voit Patrick Balcani
moins de temps de prison que nous, on a
passé en confinement,
qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire ? Quel
message ça fait passer à la population ?
Est-ce que ça fait passer le message
d'une justice qui fait très attention à
l'état de santé des gens incarcérés ?
Est-ce que c'est ça vous inspire quoi ?
Alors déjà vous comparez le confinement
pour vous à à la prison. C'est c'est
intéressant euh parce que c'est quelque
chose qu'on a entendu, c'est-à-dire que
pendant la première crise du Covid, il y
a eu, je sais pas si vous vous souvenez,
des ordonnances qui ont été prises
au nom de la crise sanitaire pour vider
les prisons. Euh et on a remis comme ça
dehors pas mal de personnes puisqu'on a
on a presque évalué à 15000 personnes
qui ont pu être remis en liberté sous ce
prétexte. sanitaire en disant il faut
éviter les clusters donc on va essayer
au nom de la surpopulation carcérale de
mettre des personnes de et au même
moment on entendait justement moi je
l'ai entendu aussi c'est incroyable nous
on nous enferme alors qu'on est des bons
citoyens et on a rien fait et eux qui
sont des délinquants finalement on les
remet dehors. Ce qui est ce qui est
illogique puisqueen fait la prison est
aussi une forme de confinement si on
réfléchit et pour certains, il y en a
qui sont repartis dehors et qui avait
peut-être même pas de de lieu où résider
et cetera et cetera. Euh donc, j'entends
j'entends votre question. Après, je
pense que c'est difficile de faire ce
raccourci. La la vraie question, c'est
dans notre société démocratique euh
comment on lutte contre la corruption
euh en règle générale et en particulier
qui vient des hommes politiques et
est-ce que on est tolérant
ou des femmes politiques ?
Oui, bien sûr. Du genre, j'allais dire
là pour le coup des hommes et des femmes
politiques. Est-ce qu'on est tolérant
par rapport à ça ? Mais la question
qu'il faudrait se poser même avant,
c'est est-ce qu'on a déjà les outils et
ça c'est très intéressant et les moyens
déjà de lutter contre contre cette
corruption.
C'est très intéressant. Alors oui, alors
ce qu'il faut quand même savoir et
excusez-moi, c'est que juste je termine
là-dessus, c'est que sur des classements
qui sont faits au niveau européen ou qui
sont faits par des organismes de de
lutte et qui qui analysent la lutte
contre la corruption, la France est mal
classée déjà, il faut le savoir. elle
est mal classée, on a des
recommandations et on estime que
justement il faut renforcer
notre justice pour avoir des outils
efficaces de lutte contre ce qu'on peut
appeler la cri financière, la corruption
et cetera et cetera. Et ce mouvement-là
en plus est boosté entre guillemets par
une législation et par une communication
politique qui dit "Nous voulons une
démocratie exemplaire, nous voulons une
démocratie transparente" et il y a eu
beaucoup de lois qui ont été votées
parce qu'on on on avait aussi des
ambiguités dans notre système juridique.
Pendant très longtemps, on avait jamais
clarifié par exemple le financement des
partis politiques. Tant qu'on avait pas
justement mis un cadre légal extrêmement
clair, extrêmement précis, c'est vrai
que le financement des partis politiques
n'était pas propice à un environnement
extrêmement sain du côté, j'allais dire
peut-être des infractions qui pouvaient
avoir lieu. Donc tout ça c'est un long
mouvement où la France n'est n'est pas
du tout,
j'allais dire exemplaire en fait mais
tend à le devenir. Et la création par
exemple du parquet national financier
fait partie des outils des outils
référencés pour aider justement à cette
lutte. Mais
le PNF c'est quoi ? C'est un joli petit
air de flut ? C'est une coquille vide.
C'est un truc qui a été mis là pour
faire un effet de manche parce que c'est
quelque chose qui est totalement vide de
l'intérieur. Ils ont pas les moyens, ils
ont pas de quoi enquêter. Il y a
tellement de dossiers, il y a peut-être
des pressions à gauche à droite.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Alors, il y a il y a plein de questions
dans votre question. Le parquet national
financier, vous avez totalement raison,
pourrait être analysé dans un premier
temps comme une opération de
communication politique puisque tout le
monde le sait, ça a été créé après
l'affaire Causc. qui a eu un
retentissement extrêmement important
puisque celui qui était en charge de
lutter contre la fraude fiscale se fait,
j'allais dire euh
se fait prendre sur ce dont il est censé
être celui qui va lutter contre puisque
lui-même on lui a reproché euh de
l'évasion fiscale. Euh donc ça ça crée
un scandale évidemment. Euh et ce qui
est intéressant et excusez-moi parce que
j'ai un peu l'esprit d'escalier donc je
ferai peut-être pas mal de digressions
mais vous me ramenez au centre dès que
vous pouvez.
Si on peut
si on peut exactement si vous pouvez
mais je vous incite à le faire c'est de
voir que souvent les plus gros scandales
financiers en France c'est un vrai sujet
ce que je vous dis sont le fait soit
d'articles de presse
c'est quand même intéressant donc là
c'était le canard enchaîné il me semble
sur l'affaire Causac Médiia part aussi
mais ça peut être exactement médiia part
euh très peu euh et au risque de souvent
de leur quelques lanceurs d'alerte et on
sait très bien que là-dessus on a encore
beaucoup de progrès à faire pour les
lanceurs d'alerte même s'il y a eu la
loi Sapin 2, mais bon, on sait très bien
aussi que on connaît aussi tout tous ces
défauts et et et comment cette loi Sapin
2 neutralise aussi d'une certaine
manière la capacité des lanceurs
d'alerte. Mais euh en ça veut dire que
en terme de prévention et d'outil de
prévention euh l'État euh est presque un
peu à l'aveugle puisqueen fait elle
dépend de dénonciation et souvent même
les dénonciations soit elles sont le
fait de de d'article de presse ou de
journaux d'investigation ou euh de
vengeance personnelle, de délation.
Voyez, si vous voulez, il y a pas une
politique, c'est ça que je voudrais
dire. Il y a pas une stratégie en amont
ou une politique extrêmement forte. euh
à ce moment-là pour aller récupérer ses
infractions, les traquer et cetera et
cetera. Ça c'était au moment de
l'affaire KUAC. Donc on crée un parquet
national financier dont on pourrait dire
à l'époque que c'est une opération euh
de communication pour étouffer le
scandale et faire diversion et cetera et
cetera. En fait, quand on crée un outil
comme ça euh un instant T, on sait
jamais ce qui va devenir quelques années
plus tard. Et le parquet national
financier a pris un essort et a pris
sans doute aussi une doctrine maintenant
à des outils et est embarqué aussi par
ce mouvement plus général au niveau
européen de lutte contre la corruption.
Donc non, ce n'est pour répondre à votre
question aujourd'hui c'est pas un outil
de pacotille. Euh oui, ça a été sans
doute une opération de communication
politique très importante au moment de
l'affaire qu'USAC en disant bon
maintenant ça suffit, ça peut plus durer
comme ça. Mais par contre ce que l'on
peut dire, c'est ce que je commençais à
vous dire sur la manière dont les les
affaires sortent qui n'est pas
obligatoirement très saine puisque euh
elles peuvent sortir aussi pour abattre
un ennemi politique
selon le camp où l'on se trouve ou une
instrumentalisation par la presse. c'est
que justement
le parquet est véré aussi comme ça
justement que en fait le parquet
national financier souffre exactement
des mêmes mot que tous les parquets en
France à savoir que on a une vraie
difficulté à avoir une anticipation
avoir une vraie stratégie
de ciblage
vraie indépendance
oui mais d'outils aussi et ça il faut il
faut réfléchir dans le couple qui est
formé avec la police également parce que
la justice En réalité,
elle est aveugle sans la police. Donc ça
veut dire que derrière aussi, il faut
penser l'articulation avec une police,
je dis police gendarmerie he évidemment
qui soit également outillé
intellectuellement, formé,
je vois que ça vous fait rire, former,
c'est-à-dire avec des des des personnes
qui ont la compétence.
J'ai pas terminé. Ensuite, il faut que
cette articulation fonctionne bien avec
la justice. Après, et je dis après, mais
c'est c'est c'est
euh c'est secondaire mais c'est pas
subsidiaire. Il faut également avoir les
moyens humains et euh la capacité aussi
à utiliser les nouvelles technologies
qui sont pour nous qui peuvent être
extrêmement intéressantes sur notamment
sur ces ces contentieux de de fraude.
Euh voilà, tout ça c'est un ensemble si
vous voulez qui ne peut en aucun cas se
réduire à une formule facile qui
pourrait dire simplement ça sert à rien
ou ça marche pas. C'est tout le système
en fait de la justice qui est faible par
rapport à la lutte contre la criminalité
organisée puisque ou en tout cas
financière euh qui se retrouve au
parquet national financier.
Alors pour résumer euh vous m'arrêtez si
je me trompe, on a une police qui
travaille dans 10 conditions
déplorables, des commissariats qui puent
la piss et je vous passe les détails. On
a un budget pour le ministère de la
justice qui est l'équivalent
d'un pouem de pouem de notre budget.
Euh, on a des magistrats, des juges, des
avocats sous pression qui travaillent
dans des conditions délétaires.
On fait quoi ? On sort dans la rue, on
demande justice, on demande que justice
soit faite, on se coule cocotier, on
fait quoi ?
Alors, le c'est qui ? Moi, je
c'est la population.
Voilà. D'accord. Parce que c'est pas la
même chose.
Qui payent des impôts.
Oui.
Qui payent leur salaire. Oui. Alors
cette question elle a c'est pour ça je
vous pose la question comme ça, elle est
intéressante dans le on parce que on
vous met dans aussi hein.
Oui. Alors c'est pas pareil justement
parce que le 11 c'est la population
c'est par exemple ce qui s'est passé en
Italie sur la mafia et cetera. Il peut y
avoir à un moment donné dans la
population euh une acceptation ou pas,
une collaboration ou pas, une
indifférence ou pas euh avec des
systèmes, j'allais dire de type mafieux,
hein, de criminalité organisée ou de
criminé financière. Euh donc la
sociologie d'un territoire, d'une nation
par rapport à ce qu'elle accepte ou ce
qu'elle n'accepte pas sur ce ce genre
d'infraction est très importante à
évaluer. Premièrement. Deuxièmement, la
population euh
peut toujours agir et doit toujours
agir. Faut-il encore euh qu'il y ait une
conscience collective ou une conscience
citoyenne. Euh il y a des pays qui l'ont
plus que d'autres. Je pense à
l'Allemagne par exemple.
Très clairement l'Allemagne
pays nordique.
Les pays nordiques. Exactement. Mais
alors les pays nordiques, ils ont en
plus une culture euh qui fait qu'ils
sont beaucoup moins dans l'acceptation
hein, parce que nous là aussi il y a il
y a du culturel entre les pays
nordiques, les pays latins dans une
forme d'acceptation ou pas. Et ça tient
sans doute aussi à une structuration
même quasi religieuse hein par rapport à
vision luarienne.
Exactement. Tout à fait. de rigueur euh
et la la manière dont dont on conçoit et
et dont on accepte certaines choses.
Donc tout ça n'est pas transposable non
plus d'un pays à l'autre. Mais ce que
l'on peut ce que l'on peut voir c'est
que justement cette conscience
collective que que tout le monde appelle
de ses vœux, c'est aussi le le baromètre
d'une démocratie en bonne santé et d'une
démocratie qui fonctionne bien. Il est
pas un
On est en démocratie en France. Oui, on
est en démocratie. Mais la démocratie
c'est
Vous êtes sûr de ça ?
La démocratie c'est un cadre si vous
voulez. C'est comme si vous me dites là
vous êtes dans un hôpital, c'est très
bien mais si dans l'hôpital il y a pas
de médecin, il y a pas de médicament, il
y a personne qui vous soigne et que vous
attendez 3 he avant qu'on vous prenne en
charge, vous êtes bien dans un hôpital
mais l'hôpital fonctionne mal. C'est
pareil pour la démocratie. Oui, on est
dans un cadre démocratique. Dire
l'inverse euh serait faux, mais ça veut
pas dire que la démocratie est en bonne
santé. C'est ça que je veux dire.
C'est-à-dire que voilà, après ce qui une
fois que vous avez dit ça, il faut voir
comment ça s'organise et comment ça vit
ou comment ça dépérit. Et il y a des
signaux d'alerte aujourd'hui dans notre
démocratie
très clairement et on l'a vu pendant la
crise du Covid euh qui doivent nous
interpeller sur une dévitalisation. Euh
ah ben alors très clairement euh les
signaux enfin très clairement il y en a
plusieurs évidemment mais moi je parle
en tant que juriste.
Au moins trois
au moins trois euh je pense que euh
alors c'est peut-être pas celui que vous
allez vous allez attendre en premier
mais je je pense que quand une
démocratie fonctionne toujours aux
urgences
symptomatique. C'est très symptomatique
parce que ça veut dire que on n'est plus
dans une gouvernance qui anticipe et qui
est sereine et qui et qui qui peut
justement résister euh aux crises. On
est euh dans euh dans dans quelque chose
qui est inquiétant par rapport si vous
voulez aux événements. C'est-à-dire que
une démocratie ça doit être quelque
chose, ça doit être un cadre, une
architecture qui est stable et qui est
sereine. Quand elle est toujours aux
urgences, c'est quelque chose qui ne va
pas. Et c'est ce qui ne va pas. Est-ce
que c'est les personnes qui gouvernent ?
Est-ce que c'est les structures qui sont
défaillantes ? Tout ça ça s'analyse, ça
serait peut-être un peu trop long.
Premièrement, donc là c'est vrai que ce
ce ce mode de fonctionnement aux
urgences dont la justice est habituée
parce que nous on est toujours aux
urgences, c'est on a beaucoup de choses
en commun avec euh avec les hôpitaux
pour ça. Euh et n'est pas est un signal
à mon avis extrêmement intéressant.
On va où ? Ensuite, dans les autres
signaux, si je puis me permettre, euh
c'est évidemment euh dans cette façon de
procéder, on voit très bien euh que euh
une démocratie, c'est un équilibre
permanent à construire et à conserver
entre plusieurs pouvoirs, pouvoir
législatif, le pouvoir exécutif. Nous,
on n'est pas vraiment un pouvoir mais on
est une autorité judiciaire. Or là, on a
très clairement une confusion, une
confusion euh qui fait que euh moi, j'ai
parlé d'un coup d'état législatif quand
par exemple le Conseil constitutionnel a
accepté, alors c'est un peu technique
mais c'est quand même très intéressant
que les ordonnances qui sont prises
comme mode de fonctionnement permanent,
c'est-à-dire euh
ont quasi une valeur normative
législative. Ça veut dire quoi
clairement ? ce que j'appelle un coup
d'état législatif, ça veut dire qu'en
fait l'exécutif
peut se passer du législatif puisque par
voie d'ordonnance, il peut prendre de la
norme autant qu'il veut. Donc ça c'est
déjà un très mauvais signal dans
l'équilibre des pouvoirs. Et dans le
troisème, j'allais dire signal d'alerte
puisque sur cette démocratie qui me
semble en forme de oui de pas de
dévitalisation ou de délitement, je sais
pas ce qu'il faudrait dire, ou de
déflagration,
c'est que l'autorité judiciaire
elle-même aussi qui doit être gardienne
des libertés euh et est embarqué aussi
dans ce mouvement puisqu'on a vu aussi
des une tendance à la réduction des
libertés sur lequel on résiste. plus ou
moins bien d'ailleurs, plus ou moins
bien. Donc c'est là où on voit que la
démocratie c'est c'est un organisme
vivant et que rien n'est acquis et que
cet équilibre permanent peut-être
déséquilibré et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il est déséquilibré.
Les libertés en France, elles vont
comment ? Quand on voit que maintenant
on peut faire on peut se faire ficher
avec nos opinions politiques, nos
tendances en un clinquement de doigt,
est-ce que c'est annonciateur d'une
radicalisation du pouvoir ?
Alors, je pense que quand un pouvoir
n'est plus puissant,
il est dans le contrôle de sa
population. C'est-à-dire que, je
m'explique, c'est-à-dire que on sent que
le pouvoir perd son pouvoir. Excusez-moi
cette
et il se crispe d'une certaine façon
parce qu'il ne contrôle pas la situation
et comme il contrôle pas la la situation
et ce que je viens de décrire
c'està-dire c'est cette modalité
d'urgence permanente et et de
modification législative qui est un vrai
sujet aussi ça on pourra peut-être en
reparler mais c'est de toujours faire de
la norme de la norme pour pour s'ajuster
fait que d'une certaine façon il y a un
déplacement c'est-à-dire que
au lieu d'exer er sa puissance
stratégique sur tous les domaines qui
sont les siens. Au lieu de gouverner, il
est davantage dans l'administration, ce
qui produit de la norme et du coup, il
est il est davantage dans le contrôle de
sa population qui lui fait peur d'une
certaine façon. et et les textes que
vous avez évoqués euh sont très très
choquants en réalité ces décrets parce
que d'abord ce sont des décrets et ce
sont des décrets euh qui sont là en
effet pour ficher euh vous l'avez très
bien dit. Alors, c'est toujours au nom
d'un prétexte de sécurité
euh nationale. Et encore là, il y aurait
il y aurait quand même une incise à
faire parce que on confond deux notions
euh qui ne sont pas à confondre qui est
la sécurité et la sûreté de l'État. Et
ça pose la question d'ailleurs à quoi
sert la police ? Est-ce que la police
sert à protéger la population ou à
sauver l'État ? Et c'est pas du tout le
même angle. C'est-à-dire et là on voit
très bien que l'État se protège
en voulant ficher sa population. Alors,
c'est ce décret qui va permettre
d'élargir euh les signalements faits par
le ministère de l'intérieur sur vos
opinions politiques, ce qui est quand
même nouveau, sur vos opinions
religieuses, sur vos sur vos appartences
syndicales ou philosophiques. Donc
voilà, dans des fichiers qui peut-être
existaient hein, peut-être que ces
décrets ne sont là que pour mettre à
jouraliser ce qui était déjà des choses
qui existaient plus ou moins à jour et
et tout ça passe en plus parce qu'on
parle de justice devant la justice
administrative et ça c'est une
singularité française. Il faut quand
même bien avoir conscience que depuis la
Révolution française, on a deux ordres
de juridiction. Et les deux ordres de
juridiction, la justice administrative
et la justice judiciaire, euh c'est une
singularité française. Les autres pays
n'ont pas deux ordres de juridiction.
C'est un héritage
aussi qui a été renforcé par Napoléon.
Mais euh ça pose un problème parce que
du coup on voit que l'État a tendance
plus à privilégier dans ses modalités
d'action et de contrôle la justice
administrative qui valide. Et la justice
administrative, le Conseil d'État a
quand même validé énormément de choses
euh pendant pendant la crise du Covid
sur les libertés. Mais c'est eux aussi
qui ont validé tout l'état d'urgence sur
ce qui a été fait au moment des atts
terroristes et cetera et cetera. Donc si
vous voulez, c'est une vraiment une
singularité française qu'il faudra sans
doute à un moment donné interroger.
Question internet. La justice comme les
hôpitaux, c'est une situation d'urgence.
Ouais.
Pour les gilets jaunes, les comparutions
immédiates étaient-elles aussi
nécessaires que la prise en charge des
borniers et autres victimes de violence
policière ?
Alors la la gestion du maintien de
l'ordre des des gilets jaunes est sans
doute une situation paroxistique de de
ce que le pouvoir a eu peur en réalité.
euh de de ce peuple qui a émergé dans
dans les ronds-points et qui un moment a
a fait que ils ont perdu le contrôle du
maintien de l'ordre. Ça c'est c'est
certain. Et d'ailleurs maintenant, il y
a une nouvelle doctrine he du maintien
de l'ordre. Quand je dis ils ont perdu
le contrôle, c'estàdire que euh en terme
de masse, il y en a eu partout sur tout
le territoire euh de plus en plus
nombreux et et en fait la police a eu
beaucoup de mal à si vous voulez d'abord
à anticiper le mouvement, ce qui est un
vrai sujet.
De quoi ? Ils ont eu du mal à anticiper
le mouvement parce que ils sont
qu'ils n'ont pas vu la crise venir, on
va bien
parce qu'ils sont déconnectés.
Alors quand je dis la police, c'est
peut-être un peu un peu facile, mais en
tout cas le pouvoir politique via ces
services de renseignement qui sont là
pour ça n'ont pas n'ont pas vu la crise
des gilets jaunes arrivé, ça c'est sûr.
Il
les services de renseignement sont là
pour l'état ou pour les politiques ? Je
comprends pas bien là.
Alors, les services de renseignement
pour le coup sont là justement euh pour
alerter
l'État si vous voulez de menaces
potentielles. Donc ça c'est ça c'est
tout à fait normal. Mais si je je pense
que la crise
menace, je je comprends pas. Les gilets
jaunes, c'était une menace. Non non, je
parle pas des géné, je parle en général,
mais ils ont ils ont ils ont quand même
des capteurs
sur le territoire qui qui peut qui
auraient pu peut-être laisser penser
qu'il y avait des choses qui ils ont
rien vu venir mais ils ont peut-être
rien vu venir parce que justement la
spécificité des gilets jaunes, c'est que
c'était pas très organisé. Ça a été un
il y a eu quelque chose d'assez spontané
d'ailleurs.
Je peux je peux vous couper ?
Bien sûr.
Ils n'ont rien vu venir. Je suis pas
d'accord.
C'est c'est peut-être que
dans un premier temps, j'entends Oui.
La personne qui est sur le terrain qui
fait remonter à son chef, il dit chef
chef ça va pas. Est-ce que le chef va
transmettre à son chef que ça va pas ?
Alors je vous répondez
c'estàd que les gens n'ont pas envie de
faire passer des informations qui
pourraient nuire à leur carrière. Donc
c'est c'est toujours tout va bien.
Alors il y a deux choses. Il il y a a y
il y a deux choses dans dans votre
question. Et alors, il y a il y a ce
premier aspect qui est possible, qui est
toujours possible, c'est-à-dire que euh
ne pas faire d'histoire, c'est ne pas
avoir d'histoire. Enfin, ne pas faire
remonter. Non, non, mais ce que je veux
dire, ne pas c'est le vieil adage,
pardon.
Le vieillage administration, c'est pas
de couille, pas d'embrouille.
Tout oui, oui, tout à fait. Mais mais je
crois pas que on puisse résumer la
situation à ça. Il y a il y a aussi un
2uxème élément qui est qui est
extrêmement intéressant parce que euh
c'est un grand classique, c'est euh que
vous faites quand même votre travail,
vous faites remonter l'information selon
la bureaucratie euh bien connue euh qui
fonctionne plus ou moins bien de notre
C'est quoi la bureaucratie bien connue ?
Mais ce que je veux dire c'està-dire que
on est un système bureaucratique
la enfin tout le système aujourd'hui on
pourra parler de la justice et aussi
scérosé par une forme de de bureaucratie
ou de process extrêmement complexe. On
refait un par une petite parenthèse ou
un petit parallèle avec ce que l'on vit
aujourd'hui sur le plan sanitaire et
toute la bureaucratie pour mettre en
mouvement l'action. Mais ce que je dire
par là, il y a aussi un deuxième
phénomène qu'il faut jamais négliger,
c'est l'aveuglement du politique sur ce
qu'on lui fait remonter. C'est
c'est-à-dire cette incapacité à ce déni
Exactement. Cette incapacité à voir ou
entendre euh ce qui va arriver parce que
c'est pas possible. C'est c'est une
forme de protection d'ailleurs le déni
d'une certaine façon mais c'est aussi
quelque chose de coupable quand on est
au en fonction de responsabilité.
Donc je pense que enfin en tout cas je
suis pas je je suis pas une spécialiste
du mouvement des gilets jaunes mais il y
a il y a sans doute eu cette conjonction
des deux, c'est-à-dire à la fois un
aveuglement euh
qui qui qui s'explique par quelque chose
de très simple qui est la déconnexion.
Mais ça, je crois que là-dessus, c'est
c'est quand même une réalité très forte
entre une forme d'élite, enfin je prends
ce mot heite qui est un terme générique
et le réel, c'est-à-dire la réalité de
ce qui se passe sur le terrain. cette
déconnexion,
elle est remontée, elle est remontée
même d'ailleurs par les par, j'allais
dire, les hommes politiques de terrain,
hein, c'est-à-dire ceux qui sont sur les
territoires et qui et qui disent "Mais
il y a une déconnexion entre Paris et la
province." C'est le vieux débat entre
les Girondins et les Jacobins. Et
peut-être que d'une certaine façon les
gilets jaunes ont fait émerger la fin
d'un système qui ne fonctionne plus qui
est celui d'une hypercentralisation hein
qui qui qui est montée en puissance euh
et dont on passe son temps à dire qu'on
va faire des lois de déconcentration
pour éviter ça mais qui ne fonctionnent
pas réellement. Et cette
hypercentralisation
entraîne aussi de facto une déconnexion
parfois avec le terrain.
Mais peut-être qu'on s'éloigne aussi de
de vos questions.
C'était la question internet. Euh on va
essayer de poser une autre question
internet
mais j'ai pas répondu à la question
internet sur le fait que on est été plus
répressif parce que c'est ça il me
semble aussi la question ou peut-être
plus violent avec les gilets jaunes.
Est-ce que est-ce qu'on peut formuler la
situation d'une façon beaucoup plus
triviale ? Allez-y
hein. Les gilets jaunes, ça a mis une
pression dingue sur le le la justice, la
police, le pouvoir et on on s'est rendu
compte de leur incompétence. Ils ont eu
très très peur.
Ils ont eu très très peur. Donc ils ont
tapé très très fort comme on fait en
Corée du Nord, comme ils ont fait en
Algérie à un moment, comme ils ont fait
en Turquie parce qu'ils avaient peur de
notre tradition française qui est le
régicide.
Est-ce qu'ils ont eu peur de se faire
trancher la tête d'une vindicte
populaire qui couvait parce que la
justice rend la justice à au puissant
tranquillement. On peut aller se
planquer en Corse après avoir mis la
main dans le pot de confiture, on est
tranquille. Et les gens ont réclamé de
la justice et l'exécutif, l'élite
a senti que
l'acier allait leur passer près de la
nuque.
Alors le le mouvement des gilets jaunes,
quand vous dites ils ont réclamé de la
justice, vous avez raison, ils ont
réclamé de la justice sociale.
c'est c'est je pèse mes mots.
C'està-dire qu'en fait on on était et on
a très bien vu comment on s'est parti he
c'est sur une augmentation
de du si je me trompe pas du prix du
pétrole donc quelque chose
taxe sur les carburants.
Voilà. Exactement. Et euh et donc c'est
d'abord euh à la fois euh Oui, c'est ça.
Une demande de justice sociale sur les
classes moyennes
principalement hein, qui travaillent
parce que ceux qui ont besoin d'essence,
c'est ceux qui prennent les voitures qui
sont souvent dans les territoires qui
doivent donc c'était une charge
supplémentaire. Euh donc euh c'est c'est
d'abord ça euh qui a été réclamé. Et la
justice sociale, en effet, le premier
destinataire, vous avez raison, c'est
l'État. Enfin, c'est c'est la politique
euh c'est la politique. Donc, ils l'ont
pas vu venir euh ou ils l'ont en tout
cas mal anticipé. Ils ont surréagi,
c'est ce que vous on essaie de décrire.
Et euh s'ils ont eu peur, oui, je crois
qu'ils ont eu peur. C'est c'est tout et
et qui n'aurait pas eu peur. Après, vous
vous faites appel à l'imaginaire
collectif très fort auquel je crois
aussi du régicide. Euh oui, on est un
pays euh on est un pays de où on fait la
révolution. C'est tout à fait c'est
on faisait
Oui oui oui où on fait la révolution
c'est je c'était pas un appel bien sûr
oui où on faisait on faerit la
révolution euh parce qu'on a un pays où
on on justement on est hyper centralisé
où il y a très peu de dialogue social et
que les corps intermédiaires ont été
extrêmement affaiblis c'est un vrai
sujet he les corps intermédiaires ont
été affaiblis ils ont été d'autant plus
affaiblis que
pendant le enfin depuis le début du
quinquena ils ont été même ciblés hein,
je j'en parle alors là sous ma casquette
syndicale, hein. Et il se trouve qu'en
plus je participe au conseil économique,
social et environnemental qui qui est le
lieu justement encore de des décors des
représentations intermédiaire et ça a
été extrêmement méprisé et on voit qu'
on revient au contraire maintenant en
disant c'est ce sont des lieux
extrêmement importants justement ces
corps intermédiaires
pour calmer ce face- à faceace que vous
avez décrit euh qui normalement ne
devrait pas exister. C'est-à-dire que le
face-àface entre le le celui qui
gouverne et ceux qui sont gouvernés et
n'existe pas euh n'existait pas dans
notre société, dans la construction de
notre société puisqueen fait ce face- à
faceace, il était euh
modéré par les corps intermédiaires.
C'est les corps intermédiaires qui
étaient les porte-paroles justement euh
en fait de la société par rapport au
pouvoir. Comme les corps intermédiaires
sont extrêmement faibles, ce face- à
face qui qui a eu lieu et et vous avez
tout à fait raison, il y a sans doute
quelque chose de cet imaginaire
collectif d'une confrontation peut-être
extrêmement violente.
Question internet, quel est le budget du
ministère de la justice en France ?
Alors, c'est un budget euh alors je vais
vous donner le chiffre, mais le chiffre
veut pas dire grand-chose. Enfin, si on
si on le ramène pas autre chose. Le
budget c'est 9 milliards 9 9,2
milliards. Euh je parle, j'espère que je
me trompe pas. C'est un budget qui est
qui est en progression sur une loi de
programmation de 8 %. Notre garde des
saut s'est s'est réjoui de cette
augmentation particulière cette année.
En fait, on a eu un rattrapage de ce qui
nous avait été enlevé l'année dernière.
Donc en fait, on est juste sur une loi
de programmation. Mais ce qui est
intéressant, c'est que euh si c'est une
question qui a qui intéresse vos
auditeur, c'est qu'il faut d'abord le
comparer pour le comprendre et il faut
l'analyser aussi. Le comparer, par
exemple, euh c'est à peu près
l'équivalent du budget de la mairie de
Paris aujourd'hui, le budget de la
justice. Ça c'est une première
comparaison. C'est intéressant, je
trouve. Une deuxième comparaison, euh
c'est un budget euh qui ne va pas qu'à
la justice, je m'entends. C'est-à-dire
qu'en fait, on a on a un budget commun
avec la pénitentiaire et la
pénitentiaire, c'est-à-dire les prisons
et tout ce qui est autour de la
pénitenère
grève euh quasiment oui, je voudrais pas
me tromper, mais 40 % du budget. Donc
c'est c'est c'est un budget qui souvent
profite davantage et tant mieux pour eux
parce qu'ils en ont besoin à la
pénitentiaire qu'aux juridiction
elle-même. Sur les juridictions
elles-mêmes, c'est un budget extrêmement
faible et si on devait encore le
comparer pour juste essayer de faire un
peu de pédagogie, on a on est un des
budgets les plus faibles. Euh je crois
qu'on est le 32e budget euh
en fait dans les ministères, on a un
budget extrêmement faible. Mais si on
devait le comparer par exemple euh à
l'Allemagne, on est à un budget euh qui
est à peu près deux fois moindre
puisqu'on on doit consacrer à peu près
près de 60 presque 70 € euh par personne
en France, là où d'autres consacrent
comme l'Allemagne 120 ou 130 €. Donc
est-ce que c'est fait à dessin ?
Pardon ?
Est-ce que c'est fait à dessin ?
Oui. Alors moi je pense que oui. Alors à
dessin ça veut pas dire malveillant. Je
veux dire, oui, ce sont des choix
politiques. Oui, ce sont des choix
politiques. La la justice n'a jamais été
dotée d'un de de bons budgets. Alors, ça
peut être pour plein de raisons
différentes. D'abord parce que ça ne les
intéresse pas, parce que c'est une façon
d'affaiblir la justice peut-être, parce
que c'est pas une priorité. Mais euh
quand on voit par exemple mais mais ce
qui est dommage et alors ça c'est une
question un peu plus économique, c'est
qu'en fait le budget de la justice et
comme le fonctionnement de la justice
n'est pas vu et ça c'est un vrai
problème stratégique à mon avis de
gouvernance d'ailleurs n'est pas vu
comme un investissement mais comme un
coût. Et ça ça change tout. C'est-à-dire
que je pense que la justice pourrait
être un investissement pour l'État.
D'abord, un investissement
politique, social, évidemment
symbolique, très fort, mais un
investissement aussi économique.
C'est-à-dire que comme la justice est
faible, elle coûte plus qu'elle
rapporte. Elle pourrait rapporter. Je je
je prends un petit exemple euh assez
récent. Euh on a un magistrat euh qui
récemment a fait une étude sur la fraude
sociale qui que je connais pas mais qui
que qui s'appelle Charles Pratz qui
vient de sortir un livre qui s'appelle
Le cartel des fraudes. Bon, un magistrat
euh a fait une étude. Alors, il a il a
travaillé avec des des parlementaires,
il y a eu des commissions notamment au
Sénat et il a mis tout seul en avant le
fait que la fraude sociale coûtait par
rapport à ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure de 9 milliards qui est notre
budget coûtait à peu près 50 milliards.
C'est-à-dire qu'on avait un manque sur
la fraude sociale de 50 milliards.
Peut-être que c'est même plus mais on
est déjà par an. H
imaginez une justice stratège
qui dit je cible c'estàd je cible en
dans un budget réduit je cible ce qui
m'intéresse, ce qui est le plus grave,
ce qui est le plus important et ce qui
peut aussi rapporter, c'est-à-dire
abonder au ministère de la justice. Si
on on travaillait mieux et ça rejoint
votre première question sur les fraudes
du départ, si on ciblait, si on était
proactif et stratège par exemple des
contentieux où il y a des vrais enjeux
et on peut ramener aussi de l'argent,
cet argent qui pourrait d'ailleurs du
coup être utilisé par la justice. Je
sais pas si vous mz 50 milliards de
fraudes sociales qui partent. Donc vous
voyez, il y a des stratégies et c'est ce
que font les Italiens. C'est ce qu'ils
ont fait. C'est pour ça que je fais un
petit parallèle. Excusez-moi, je suis un
peu longue mais c'est vachement
intéressant.
Euh c'est ce qu'ils ont fait parce que
c'est à la fois c'est un effet de
justice, ça c'est de bonnes gouvernance,
de stratégie et aussi euh de démocratie
intelligente. Les Italiens par exemple
quand ils se sont attaqués à la mafia,
très intéressant, il a de la mafia en
France.
Oui, les Italiens quand ils se sont
attaqués à la mafia, ils ont confisqué,
ils ont eu une politique de confiscation
extrêmement importante des biens
illicites acquis par la mafia. Donc
déjà, il y avait ce côté très
spectaculaire et pédagogique. Vous
faites quelque chose de mal et ça répond
aussi à votre première question.
Pourquoi on est si faible finalement
avec la corruption ? Et bien regardez,
non seulement vous allez aller en
prison, ça va être voilà des vraies
peines, on va tout vous confisquer et ce
qu'on vous confisque, on va l'utiliser
pour faire par exemple une école, un
centre social. Et c'est-à-dire que la
population du coup voit que la
confiscation du crime sert à la
collectivité. C'est extrêmement
intéressant d'ailleurs comme démarche et
du coup à la fois non seulement la
justice devient non pas un coût mais un
investissement et un investissement qui
va même beaucoup plus loin parce que sur
le plan démocratique, sur le plan
social, sur le plan symbolique ça a une
visibilité, ça a un intérêt. On remet du
commun et on remet une forme de morale
si vous voulez dans l'action de la
justice. Je trouve cet exemple
extrêmement intéressant. Alors, la
France il vient, on on met 15 ans en
général à chaque fois pour trouver les
choses bien. Euh euh non non mais on
prend des textes et puis après on on
attend longtemps. Alors on est sur ce
mouvement puisqu'on a un organisme qui
s'appelle la grasque euh et qui commence
à confisquer mais les magistrats
savaient pas trop n'avaient pas trop
l'habitude et tout. On on n pas la
culture du contrôle en France, il faut
quand même bien l'avoir en tête. Et euh
on a un rapport aussi à l'argent euh qui
qui n'est pas obligatoirement très sain
puisque on a beaucoup de mal à à mettre
des sanctions financières extrêmement
fortes là où d'autres pays n'ont aucun
problème. Je pense par exemple aux
Américains quand ils vous mettent une
fonction financière en général vous vous
en soit
surtout chez ces chez leurs alliés, ils
aiment bien.
Mais c'est stratégique hein.
Oui oui à chaque fois ça s'appelle se
prendre des couteaux dans le dos.
Mais on est content on est content.
C'est nos alliés. Vous parliez de fraude
sociale ? Ouais.
Euh, parlons un peu de criminalité en
col blan d'évasion fiscale et de de tous
ces ces ces gros requins. La la
l'évasion fiscale, ça représente combien
?
Alors, j'ai objectivement euh j'ai
aucune idée de ce que ça de ce que ça
représente. Je ne sais pas. par rapport
à la fraude sociale.
Je pense que c'est je je dirais sans
doute une bêtise si je dis je pense que
c'est supérieur mais euh sans doute même
très supérieur. Mais encore une fois la
fraude fiscale c'est un magistrat qui a
évalué un morceau de fraude fiscale qui
est déjà à 50 milliards.
Peut-être que c'est beaucoup plus non
mais je veux dire je ne sais pas je je
pense que la fraude et alors ça c'est
c'est intéressant parce que c'est ce que
je disais là tout à l'instant c'est que
on a un système qui est quand même assez
particulier en France.
Je sais pas s'il faut en faire une
analyse socioéconomique culturelle, j'en
sais rien. C'est qu'on a pas cette
culture du contrôle. Par exemple, quand
vous êtes à l'audience, moi c'est
toujours quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a
surprise. Euh vous devez juger en
individualisant la peine. D'accord ? Or
pour individualiser la peine, il faut
connaître la personne et tout. Et moi,
j'ai fait beaucoup de pénal, quand
quelqu'un commet une une infraction, à
la fin, vous lui dites combien vous
gagnez,
qu'est-ce que vous faites, quels sont
vos revenus et cetera et cetera. Et
pendant très longtemps, et c'est encore
le cas parce qu'on a pas les moyens,
c'est du déclaratif.
Donc la personne peut vous dire "Mais
écoutez moi madame, je n'ai rien et
cetera et ça peut être faux, je n'en
sais rien, je n'ai pas les moyens
obligatoirement de le vérifier." Donc si
vous voulez, ce système de confiance
entre guillemets ou de de de déclaratif
et est un défaut à mon avis puisque du
coup ça c'est une forme de laxisme d'une
certaine façon si vous voulez de ne
jamais vérifier. Alors, ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut jamais croire ce que les gens
vous disent, mais vous ne pouvez le la
confiance n'exclut pas le contrôle, si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire. Donc euh
j'ai eu à un moment des fonctions à
l'exécution des peines. J'étais
vice-procure en charge de l'exécution
des peines. Donc, j'allais euh très
souvent en prison.
Vous pourriez faire exécuter une peine
de mort ?
Pardon, excusez-moi.
Vous pourriez faire exécuter une peine
de mort si elle revenait en France ?
Euh non.
Vous feriez quoi ? Ce serait un cas de
conscience pour vous ? Oui.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des cas de
conscience ?
Euh, est-ce que j'ai déjà eu un cas de
conscience au moment de juger ? Non.
Alors, je pense que j'en aurais si s'il
y avait la peine de mort, ça serait
compliqué. Oui. Euh je pense que non, je
ne pourrais pas faire requérir la peine
de mort puisque euh c'est votre
question. Est-ce que j'ai eu déjà des
cas de conscience ? Oui, je pense que et
c'est bon de de se dire est-ce qu'on a
pris la bonne décision ? Est-ce qu'on
s'est pas trompé ? Oui, je pense que ce
ce dialogue avec soi-même, il est il est
sain, il est nécessaire, il faut mais il
est il est sain et nécessaire si il
débouche sur quelque chose. Si on est
toujours en train de se dire "Ou là là,
est-ce que j'ai bien fait, pas bien fait
?" C'est pas sain ça par contre. Mais le
fait de pouvoir se remettre en question
et d'avoir cette introspection me semble
tout à fait à la fois une exigence
morale et quelque chose de tout à fait
sain. Encore encore faut-il, je vous
dire, le dépasser, c'est-à-dire voilà
que cette remise en question, elle
débouge sur l'action. Euh oui oui bien
sûr. Aujourd'hui je ne je ne je ne serai
pas la même magistrate qu'il y a 20 ans
à mes débuts. C'est sûr.
Quand on nomme une un magistrataire
un magistrat junior sur une affaire un
peu compliquée, c'est un risque, c'est
fait à dessin. Pourquoi vous souriez ?
Non parce que c'est c'est une catégorie
qui n'existe pas. Le magistrat junior.
Donc je c'est voulais dire un jeune
magistrat qui sort de l'école ou qui a
peu d'expérience.
Alors, le peu d'expérience n'est pas
obligatoirement lié à l'âge d'ailleurs
pour commencer parce que on a aussi des
magistrats qui arrivent en parcours de
carrière, donc ils sont déjà âgés mais
qui peuvent prendre pour la première
fois des fonctions. Et puis on
fonctionne dans notre pays sur un mythe
du magistrat qui est capable d'occuper
toutes les fonctions tout au long de sa
carrière. C'est-à-dire que dans une
carrière de magistrat, on est
interchangeable d'une certaine façon.
C'est-à-dire qu'on peut passer du pénal
au civil. Il y en a qui le font pas.
Mais c'est possible. C'est possible de
changer de métier. Donc vous pouvez très
bien avoir 20 ans d'expérience et
recommencer à zéro sur une fonction.
C'est pour ça que je souris à la
catégorie junior. Voilà. Et donc est-ce
que on les met sur certaines fonctions à
dessin ? Non, on en est bien incapable.
Il faudrait pour ça avoir une maîtrise
déjà un début de maîtrise de RH. Ce que
l'on n pas.
Question internet. Condamner des
personnes pour les infractions liées au
Covid, ça vous fait un cas de conscience
?
lié au cas de Covid, c'est-à-dire je je
comprends pas, c'est-à-dire le fait de
pas respecter le confid
plus de trois fois ou des choses comme
ça.
Oui. Alors, c'est alors moi je suis plus
en juridiction euh puisque je j'exerce
maintenant des fonctions syndicales,
hein. Je je euh si j'étais en
juridiction,
il y a il y a la réponse
la réponse, j'allais dire
institutionnelle qui est celle de dire
"Le magistrat fait ce que la loi lui
ordonne et cetera." Voilà. Et après, il
y a il y a la réponse du magistrat de
terrain qui dit "Mais oui, après il y a
toujours la latitude d'apprécier
concrètement les situations." Euh voilà,
je je pense que les les c'est compliqué
parce que comme on est un pays latin, ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure où les gens
enf ne respectent pas toujours partout
les consignes, c'est vrai que souvent on
est obligé d'aller dans le répressif,
mais c'est pas sur ces infractions que
je serai le plus à l'aise. Je reconnais.
Vous seriez plus allé sur quel type
d'infraction ?
Ah bah sur la criminalité organisée, sur
les crimes, sur les sur ce que moi
j'estime être les priorités d'une
politique pénale digne de ce nom.
Il y a de la mafia en France.
C'est ce que alors vous vous ce que vous
appelez mafia, j'appelle ça la crémité
organisée en réalité. La mafia, bon
évidemment c'est comme ça c'est un côté
culturel de de l'Italie. Euh mais il y a
pas que l'Italie qui a des mafias. Oui.
Oui. Oui. Tout à fait. Euh oui, ça ça me
semble par contre des choses extrêmement
intéressantes et on est sur euh de la
crémité déjà de de haut niveau, de
hautees fréquences pour prendre un autre
terme.
La ramification vont jusqu'où ?
On est dans une on est de plus en plus
dans un monde totalement ouvert. Donc
les ralifications, elles sont elles
étaient déjà pour les pour les premières
mafias évidemment déjà transnationales.
Elles le sont de plus en plus et elles
sont facilitées à mon avis par
de la France hein.
Oui. Elles sont facilitées par des
choses très simples. D'abord il y a il y
a des nouveaux territoires de
criminalité organisé qu'il faut pas
négliger et il y a des nouvelles
occurrences. Les nouveaux territoires
évidemment, c'est tout ce qui est cyber,
le dark web. Là, je je voyais encore
avant-hier Europol qui avait fait une
très belle opération sur le dark web.
C'est extrêmement intéressant de voir
euh comment cette criminalité de masse
de masse est en train de se développer
sur ces nouveaux territoires qui sont
facilités. Un par le fait que on a
toujours un temps de retard, police
justice.
Trois temps de retard. Alors, 3 temps de
retard, renseignement, police, justice.
Bon euh et puis c'est aussi un problème
de stratégie. On est toujours on a un
problème de technologie très clairement
de de sous-investissement technologie et
de sous-investissement
aussi sur l'humain parce que la
technologie suffit pas, faut-il encore
savoir l'utiliser et la comprendre. Euh
donc ça c'est c'est une réalité. Et puis
on on a un retard aussi sur la
législation, c'est-à-dire que là-dessus,
on n'est pas très bon pour aller encore
on n' pas compris qu'il fallait être
offensif comme les Américains le sont
hein, par exemple sur sur la
législation. Euh
donc les nouvelles technologies et la
con l'hyperconnexion permet euh des
nouveaux champ infractionnel absolument
incroyable sur lequel euh on n'est pas
du tout au rendez-vous mais alors pas du
tout du tout du tout. Voilà. Donc mais
la mafia au sens traditionnel du terme
en France
ça existe.
Oui. Bah par exemple là je regardais il
y a il y a eu une une condamnation très
intéressante
à Marseille. il y a 2 jours je crois où
euh c'était une histoire de raquette
vous savez sur les restaurants et
cetera. Bon c'est typiquement pas
du raquette c'était de la protection
madame.
Oui.
Alors protection raquette ça va
d'ailleurs ça va à deux paires. La mafia
c'est quoi en été ? La mafia c'est le
territoire. C'est ça qu'il faut bien
comprendre. La mafia c'est la prise de
contrôle du territoire.
Alors ça peut être des territoires
virtuels, hein évidemment.
Mais c'est d'abord ça et et donc oui, ça
existe en France, oui, il y a des
territoires et c'est d'autant plus
intéressant que je pense que et c'est là
où on a un problème euh intellectuel,
euh c'est qu'on a du mal à sortir de nos
catégories traditionnelles pour
appréhender ce que j'appelle les
nouvelles menaces qui sont des nouvelles
menaces à la fois locales et globales,
hein. Et donc là, on est on est
totalement sur ce que vous me dites,
c'est-à-dire
c'est c'est c'est
à la fois on est sur cette société
complètement mondialisée qui est en
capacité d'avoir un système sur le plan
transnational et des activités locales
extrêmement ciblées via des
technologies, mais pas que via des
technologies et euh
politique,
pardon,
via des politiques.
Oui. Oui. Et et en fait là où on a un
problème
d'aveuglement nous, justice, police ou
État d'ailleurs parce que nous aussi on
est dans la déclinaison aussi des
impulsions des politiques pénales, c'est
que
ces nouvelles menaces ont créé ce que ce
que je reprends une catégorie des
catégories hybrides.
Et l'hybridation criminelle, c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement intéressant
parce que
on voit très bien que ça allie à la fois
des choses traditionnelles, c'est-à-dire
ce que vous par exemple le raquette, la
protection et des choses extrêmement
modernes dans les modalités d'action et
dans l'évasion et dans l'organisation,
l'influence, la pression.
Tout à fait. Et cette hybridation euh
d'ailleurs euh elle a été très bien
comprise par les Italiens. Je j'ai pas
d'action avec l'Italie mais je trouve
qu'il y a des choses très intéressantes
avec l'Italie.
L'Italie est un pays magnifique
notamment dans l'approche du terrorisme.
Pourquoi ? Parce que comme ils ont eu
une longue tradition pour lutter contre
la mafia et au péril de leur vie hein
comme tout le monde le sait puisque des
magistrats même ont été assassinés. Donc
donc ils ont été actifs puisque on les a
supprimé. c'est qu'ils ont fait peur.
Euh je dis pas que c'est c'est qu'il
faut nous supprimer, mais je veux dire
c'est quand même un indicateur
extrêmement intéressant. Euh eux depuis
longtemps, ils ont compris grâce à la
mafia euh qu'en fait euh c'était c'était
il fallait vraiment travailler sur les
territoires, c'est-à-dire sur le
renseignement, sur les indicateurs, sur
les infiltrations et ils ont eu toute
une politique extrêmement intéressante
là-dessus euh d'infiltration mafieuse et
pour faire tomber euh alors parfois vous
savez, on fait tomber pas sur
l'infraction principale mais sur des
infractions fiscales, hein. C'est comme
ça qu'on a on a fait tomber la mafie
américaine. Mais ils ont cette
connaissance et cette culture du
terrain. Ce qui fait que quand le
terrorisme d'ailleurs est arrivé hein et
ils ont eu aussi des des mouvements
forts de terrorisme, ils ont jamais
dissocié comme nous euh d'un côté la
criminé organisée mafia et de l'autre
côté le terrorisme. Nous en France, on
est dans des catégories extrêmement
différenciées
et et on a du mal à appréhender
l'hybridité. Et l'hybridité,
c'est pas l'identité, c'est simplement
de dire qu'il y a des passerelles, il y
a des porosités, il y a des modes
d'action parfois convergents, il y a des
intérêts parfois convergents, il y a des
parcours parfois qui sont intéressants.
Et sur le terrorisme par exemple,
l'approche que nous on a du terrorisme
en France, on a une approche
complètement différente.
On va on va venir sur le terrorisme.
Trois petites questions.
Est-ce que nos politiques sont
infiltrées par des systèmes mafieux ?
Oui. Non,
je réfléchis parce que la question elle
est elle est intéressante. Est-ce que
nos politiques sont sont je pense qu'
Non, il y a des pratiques, c'est pas
tout à fait pareil. Il y a des
pratiques, il y a peut-être des
territoires. On essaie des pratiques
mafieuses.
Oui, bien sûr, mais on le sait puisque
on a quand même des affaires qui sortent
régulièrement sur les par du panier de
craft du 92. Oui oui oui. Ou même dans
dans le nord de la France ou dans le sud
de la France, on a et on a des
territoires où on sait que il y a de
plus en plus de pratiques mafiauses qui
sont pas obligatoirement d'ailleurs
nationales hein, ça peut être aussi
exporté. Euh par exemple, on on a des
études très intéressantes qui sont
faites par le Casco. Je sais pas si vous
connaissez le Sirasco qui qui fait à la
fois des études
par infraction, donc ça c'est
intéressant et par territoire et montre
comment justement ça peut être par
exemple les mafias albanaises, les
mafias des pays de l'Est, des mafias de
la Russie ont leurs activités propres
propres vraiment avec des spécialités et
comment ils arrivent sur certains
territoires et ils installent cette
mafia. Oui, on a des mafias exportées
aussi et qu'il ne faut absolument pas
négliger qui peuvent selon les
territoires s'allier avec des des des
délinquents, j'allais dire nationaux et
ce qui crée ce que j'appelais tout à
l'heure encore des des phénomènes
hybrides d'association ou de concurrence
ou de concurrence. La concurrence, je
pense évidemment sur le marché des
stupes où là on a des concurrences qui
sont sanglantes. Vous parlez vous parlez
du marché des stupes, c'est très
intéressant. Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'on laisse le marché des stupes à une
petite mafia pour maintenir la paix
sociale dans les cités ? Alors ça c'est
c'est c'est qui ont quand vous dites
ont le pouvoir politique parce que
démunis incapable d'infiltrer, incapable
de surveiller correctement incapable de
donner de réponse politique. Donc il
préfère laisser ça tranquillement parce
que ça permet de faire fonctionner une
économie parallèle qui pourrait réclamer
des aides sociales. Donc comme on a plus
de budget, on les laisse autoorganiser.
C'est ça.
En en fait je sais pas au départ quelle
était la volonté. Je sais ce qui est les
résultats.
Oui. Oui, c'est ça. Voilà. Je sais
qu'aujourd'hui dans l'état où on se
trouve euh c'est que on on a on a
beaucoup trop attendu en tout cas et
qu'on a laissé s'installer des
territoires et ce qu'on appelle pour
d'autres qualifications les territoires
perdus. Mais c'est tout à fait vrai et
c'est là où je reprends ma ma
démonstration d'hybridation entre les
milieux criminels et même des des
milieux qui ont plus des visées
terroristes hein où on peut avoir des
des euh vraiment des choses extrêmement
violentes qui se mettent en place et des
systèmes euh de prise de contrôle du
territoire.
c'est que aujourd'hui, il faut bien
avoir conscience que
le phénomène est devenu extra tellement
important que je ne suis pas sûre qu'on
soit en capacité
avec les forces qui sont les nôtres. Le
système très faible du de de la justice
et de sa capacité à absorber euh ces
dossiers que soit on soit en capacité de
renverser la tendance sur certains
territoires. C'est pas c'est pas pour ça
qu'il ne faut pas le faire. Euh on a
créé un
en fait un un nouveau euh euh
département, une nouvelle cellule avec
un magistratement
euh contre contre les stupes. Il est
certain que en tout cas localement et à
certains c'est pas uniforme mais
certains territoires, on a fermé les
yeux parce que c'est on sait qu'on a
plus les moyens, on n'est pas dans un
c'est une question de rapport de force
en réalité, c'est que à un moment donné
on a on est en situation de faiblesse,
il faut le dire ou d'impuissance. Et ça
les policiers que vous avez déjà dû
interroger à plusieurs reprises, je
sais, sur sur votre chaîne vous l'ont
expliquer. C'est-à-dire que oui, on
préfère ne pas mettre le feu aux poudre
euh dans certaines cités euh parce qu'on
sait que on n'aura pas nécessairement
les moyens. Euh voilà, donc c'est une
politique qui est très très néfaste. Ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas le faire et
ça veut pas dire que c'est fait à dessin
partout. Voilà, ça peut être
Est-ce que vous pensez Est-ce que vous
pensez qu'on laisse la,
on va dire l'approvisionnement de drogue
de type cannabis et autres et qu'on
laisse faire pour éviter que la
criminalité se redirige sur des secteurs
beaucoup plus violents et qui pourraient
être beaucoup plus
être démonstratif dans les médias,
règlement de compte et la la criminalité
qui est liée à la drogue est extrêmement
violente. En réalité, la drogue est un
peu la mère de de de beaucoup
d'infractions criminelles euh du petit
du du bas du spec jusqu'en haut du spec.
C'est ça qu'on ne voit pas. C'est-à-dire
que il faut pas se leurer. La la prise
de cannabis, ça commence à l'école. Donc
déjà l'école, ça veut dire ne plus aller
à l'école, ça veut dire des violences,
ça veut dire la délinquence des mineurs,
ça veut dire du petit raquette, ça veut
dire plein de choses déjà au niveau des
mineurs. Et puis après, on monte d'un
degré, c'est-à-dire le trafic. Donc là,
c'est l'économie parallèle, donc tout ce
qui est marché noir et cetera, violence.
Puis on monte encore d'un spec,
c'est-à-dire que comment la drogue va
financer d'autres, j'allais dire
d'autres infractions ou tenir. Donc là,
on est sur du règlement de compte armé
et cetera et cetera et puis on peut
monter comme ça et puis comment on peut
tenir les gens aussi avec du trafic de
drogue. Voilà. Et puis il y a une
géopolitique de la drogue qui est
extrêmement importante avec certains
pays. Exactement. Euh oui, voilà. Donc
on tout ça est complexe euh intriqué.
Euh de mon petit point de vue de
magistrat, même si j'ai une expérience
sur la crimité organisée puisque j'en ai
fait pas mal quand j'étais au siège à
Paris, euh je faisais que pratiquement
des trafics de drogu à l'international.
Après vous avez déjà fumé un joint ?
Non, jamais. Ça m'a Alors, pour le coup,
ça ne m'attire pas du tout en plus. Mais
euh c'est peut-être parce que j'ai fait
trop de dossiers vu les les dégâts parce
que bon enfin c'est un autre sujet mais
aujourd'hui la teneur en en cannabis
enfin dans les jointsab
voilà exactement peut s'apparenter à à
des effets parfois pas très loin des
drogues dures et donc non j'ai vu des
j'ai vu trop de choses horribles avec
les drogues pour avoir envie d'y aller.
Qu'est-ce que ça je coupe c'est fait
exprès. Oui, vous avez raison. Mais
juste pour terminer, on a un problème
aussi en France, c'est les offices et on
a eu quand même pas mal de scandales.
Je je voudrais juste vous dire ça sur
les trafics de drogue. On a eu une
politique du ministère de l'intérieur
qui était une politique aussi de
communication très spectaculaire, de
prime et cetera et cetera. Ce qui fait
que euh on n' jamais eu aussi enfin on a
eu des affaires qui ont démontré euh que
même en interne au ministère de
l'intérieur, il y avait des choses qui
étaient pas très claires. Moi-même quand
j'avais des procédures, on avait on
avait des procédures sur renseignement
anonyme. Bon, on sait jamais trop qui
fait quoi exactement. C'est un mini qui
demande à être clarifié avec une
politique pénale extrêmement forte, avec
des offices centraux extrêmement forts
où ça soit pas la pression à la prime
spectaculaire, mais une véritable
stratégie d'infiltration. Si cette
stratégie d'infiltration et cette
politique de justice qui devrait être
extrêmement, j'allais dire aussi sévère,
n'est pas relayé derrière par un état ou
des gouvernements qui ne jouent pas
double jeu avec d'autres pays pour
d'autres raisons. Et voilà, on tourne si
vous voulez, on vide l'océan avec une
petite cuillère.
Dépénalisation, légalisation, qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez ? sur des sujets
difficiles. Euh dépénalisation,
légalisation. Non non non, sûrement pas.
Quoi ?
Alors par on parle de quelle drogue ?
Ça dépend.
Il y a beaucoup de drogues.
Le cannabis
euh
sous toutes ses formes.
Oui, on a il y a des pays qui ont fait
la qui qui ont fait la dépénalisation.
On dit que c'est une réussite. Je suis
pas sûr que ça soit une réussite.
Portugal. Non, c'est c'est pas
nécessairement une réité.
Le problème, c'est ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure, c'est que il y a il y a
vraiment euh une mythologie en France,
je pense, sur le cannabis à penser que
le cannabis est quasiment inoffensif,
voire curatif. Et c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs le cannabis peut être
thérapeutique hein sur certaines
formules. Le problème c'est que ce que
l'on vend aujourd'hui sur du cannabis
euh peut être extrêmement nocif
notamment sur les mineurs qui en
prennent de plus en plus jeunes. Et on a
même une étude très intéressante qui
avait été faite à Saint-Ane sur le
déclenchement de de schizophrénie enfin
bon avec des des problématiques
psychiatriques enfin extrêmement graves.
Donc je pense que non, il faut
absolument pas minorer l'impact de la
drogue et la légalisation n'empêchera
pas du tout de toute façon le trafic de
drogue parce qu'il y aura toujours un
marché moins cher et cetera. Et le tabou
est important, le tabou est est
extrêmement important euh parce que si
vous vous descendez d'un niveau, après
c'est la drogue dure si vous voulez très
clairement qui devient le tabou. Donc je
pense qu'il faut quand même garder cette
euh cette vision et euh
et puis on se trompe aussi parce que euh
aujourd'hui on a des phénomènes euh de
polyconsommation, c'est-à-dire que il
faut pas se leurer. Euh les gens qui
prennent du cannabis prennent aussi des
drogues dures, ce qu'on avait pas avant.
souvent on avait vous savez soit vous
prenez de la coque ou enfin puis on a
des nouvelles drogues comme maintenant
les amphétamines tout ça. Donc le sujet
est assez complexe et je je suis pas
sûre qu'en disant voilà on va
l'égaliser, on va régler on va régler le
problème. Non, on va régler surtout le
problème de la masse qui est un vrai
problème. Et on a une très grande
responsabilité en France sur la manière
dont on aborde, c'est que il y a pas de
vraie politique de santé publique, de
prévention. Il y a rien ou quasiment
rien qui est vraiment mis en place pour
aider les jeunes justement qui sont dans
dans les drogues et tout ça. Et là
vraiment c'est un c'est un vrai sujet.
Donc ça serait un abandon total si vous
voulez. Le système, il fonctionne pas
très bien aujourd'hui hein, l'injonction
thérapeutique parce qu'on manque de
tout, que les prises en charge sont pas
du tout à la hauteur. Pour autant, c'est
pas parce que le système fonctionne mal
euh qu'il faut euh justement peut-être
se dire "Bon ben, puisque de toute façon
on peut rien faire, autant l'égaliser."
Revenons à nos à nos très chers
politiques.
Euh quand quand nos politiques se font
taper, on a le temps, non ?
Ah, complètement.
Très bien.
Vous inquiétez pas.
Revenons à nos à nos chères politiques.
Quand ils se font prendre la main dans
le pot de confiture. OK. Euh, on leur
fait
comme les pédophiles, c'est ça ? On une
mesure d'éloignement avec impossibilité
de se représenter. C'est ça.
Alors, quand ils sont condamnés, ils
peuvent avoir une interdiction en fait.
Oui, ils peuvent ils peuvent avoir des
interdictions
d'exercer des mandats des mandats en
effet pendant un temps un temps un
certain temps. Oui, tout à fait. Je je
sais pas si c'est très prononcé mais
j'ai pas votre question est
C'est est-ce qu'on peut un petit peu
muscler ça ? C'est les dissuadés. Alors,
on va pas faire comme en Corée du Nord,
c'est-à-dire leur faire payer la balle
qui va servir à leur exécution, mais
est-ce qu'on peut un petit peu les
muscler notre notre appareil répressif
pour les dissuader vraiment ?
Alors, on peut toujours muscler. La
vraie question, c'est euh euh d'abord
une question assez simple, c'est euh les
citoyens, c'est une question que je
renvoie aux citoyens euh parce qu'elle
me semble quand même une question
d'éthique démocratique en fait. euh ont
aussi la responsabilité d'élire à
nouveau quelqu'un qui a été condamné, si
vous voulez voyez ce que je veux dire.
C'est-à-dire que qu'est-ce qui j'ai
envie euh qui me représente en politique
pour exercer un mandat ? Donc c'est
c'est déjà un problème général aussi
d'éthique générale. Comment ? Moi, la
question je me pose parce que ouais,
après on peut faire plein de choses,
hein, mais comment euh moi citoyen, je
suis prêt à aller revoter pour quelqu'un
qui a trahi ma confiance ? Après, il
faut voir aussi
où quand bien sûr. Euh donc, j'allais
dire c'est quand même, voyez une
problématique qui dépasse la stricte
problématique justice. C'est une
problématique
d'éthique en fait de toute une
collectivité.
On l'a vu alors aussi dans d'autres
pays. Euh je décidément, je vais encore
parler de l'Italie mais on l'a vu avec
Berlusconi, voilà tout ça qui a été
réélu. Bon euh, on peut le voir dans
d'autres pays. Dans les pays nordiques,
ça n'existe pas. On
a les politiques qu'on mérite.
Pardon ?
On a les politiques qu'on mérite.
Oui. Non, mais je veux dire, on est dans
un écosystème en réalité. C'està-dire
que n'oubliez jamais que la justice,
c'est aussi un produit culturel. C'est
aussi elle est aussi soustendue par à la
fois nos représentations,
nos attentes et nos exigences très
clairement. Alors après euh est-ce qu'on
peut faire mieux ? parce que c'est quand
même le sens de votre question si j'ai
bien compris depuis le début. Oui, bien
sûr qu'on peut faire mieux. On peut
toujours faire mieux. Je je suis pas
favorable à l'idée de dire d'entrée de
jeu, il faut traquer les politiques
parce que ils auront une présomption de
corruption. Voyez ce que je veux dire ?
Voilà, on a une classe politique qui est
ultra corrompue,
infiltré par la meuf.
Oui, voilà. Non, je je suis pas du tout
là-dedans. Par contre, je pense
je suis pas là-dedans parce que je ne
sais pas si c'est vrai. Objectivement,
je ne sais pas. et et et
c'est quand même c'est dangereux
démocratiquement aussi d'abonder dans ce
discours si vous voulez. Par contre là
où où je serais d'accord avec vous,
c'est que je pense qu'on peut monter en
exigence et en moral très clairement.
D'ailleurs, c'est ce que l'on fait hein,
c'est c'est un mouvement
permanent. Mais il est certain, il est
certain que euh il y a beaucoup de lois,
il y a beaucoup de procédures qui sont
des obstacles à ce que l'on pourrait euh
euh vouloir en terme de de d'efficacité.
Et euh euh on a quand même des
politiques qui eux-mêmes ne cherchent
pas à aider la justice et ça c'est un
vrai sujet, à monter en puissance sur ce
sujet-là. On le comprend hein. Vous
allez me dire ça.
Ça protège les copains
en tout cas.
Ça protège les ramorts planqués dans les
placards.
En tout cas on on ne le sent pas si vous
voulez. on ne le sent pas puisque et ça
c'est pas moi qui le dit je vais
m'abriter
derrière par exemple un juge comme Van
Rinbeck qui vient de publier un livre
pour prendre lui par exemple ou d'autres
magistrats c'estàd d'autres magistrats
que moi j'ai connu aussi dans mon
expérience syndicale que je rencontre
même encore aujourd'hui euh quand ils
ont des dossiers politiques ou
sensibles, hein des dossiers sensibles,
c'est très compliqué en réalité. D'abord
parce que
c'est pas une chance d'avoir il y en a
qui croient "Ah, c'est des super jus
chevalier blanc, il cherchent il cherche
les dossiers". Non, c'est pas vrai. Il
faut pas croire. Ce genre de dossier,
c'est plus de difficultés, parfois plus
de problèmes
qu'autre choses. Ensuite euh
quand il y a des des affaires politiques
comme ça, il y a il y a des des des
obstacles réels à notre efficacité.
Alors, il y a des obstacles visibles et
des obstacles invisibles. La hiérarchie
est un poids.
Oui, elle peut l'être. Elle peut l'être
en effet. Elle peut l'être. Il y a il y
a des obstacles invisibles. Par exemple,
moi j'ai j'ai été auditionné
à la commission qui a été faite par Hugo
Bernassilis
et Didier Paris sur les obstacles à
l'indépendance de la justice. Bon euh
moi j'ai trouvé cette cette commission
extrêmement intéressante. Bon parce que
justement elle repose aujourd'hui en
2020 la problématique bien connue des
rapports entre le politique et la
justice. C'estàdire que aujourd'hui les
politiques reprochent au magistrat de
faire de la politique
ce qui est en partie faux et en partie
ce qui est en grande partie faux mais ce
qui n'est pas totalement faux parce que
il y a des magistrats qui qui qui
revendiquent une action politique mais
c'est pas du tout la majorité et puis il
y a il y a pas de de si vous voulez il y
a pas de grand complot. Ça c'est ça ça
fonctionne pas comme ça. Pour pour pour
que ça fonctionne comme ça, il faudrait
qu'on soit solidaire. On ne l'est
vraiment pas. Mais euh à contrario, il y
a la réciprocité, c'est-à-dire que euh
il faut pas non plus que le politique
s'immisse en permanence dans la justice
pour pouvoir instrumentaliser,
neutraliser euh ou affaiblir l'activité
de la justice. Or aujourd'hui, on a un
vrai sujet
du pomoriti.
Non non non, lui
c'est un vrai sujet lui.
Non non, c'est un épiphénomène en fait.
Il faut il faut regarder ça le sur le
temps long justement. Il faut regarder
ça sur 40 ans. Ça fait 40 ans si vous
voulez que il y a une vraie difficulté
euh pour lutter contre les affaires
politico-financières. Voilà. Et tous
ceux qui ont essayé parfoisement
ou maladroitement d'ailleurs hein, parce
que je dis pas que tout ce qu'on fait
est bien et ce serait fou de le dire,
mais avec leurs moyens ou en tout cas
avec leur conviction
ont souvent rencontré des difficultés en
fait.
Soit des attaques personnelles, soit une
délégitimation, soit une
déstabilisation,
soit des dossiers qu'on vous enlève.
Vous savez, il y a plein de moyens de
neutraliser un dossier. Plein de moyens
de neutraliser un dossier. Le premier
moyen pour neutraliser un dossier
euh une fois qu'il est sorti, hein,
parce que déjà le premier moyen déjà,
c'est qu'il ne sorte jamais. Bon, mais
si
comment on fait pour que qu'il ne sorte
pas ?
On prend son téléphone, on dit "Allez
écoute mon copain, tu étais en promo
avec moi, tac tac tac, je le connais."
Non, ça marche pas comme ça. D'abord,
c'est ce que je vous disais au départ,
la justice, elle n'existe que par le
travail de la police. Nous n'oublions
jamais ça. Toutes les enquêtes
préliminaires, tout ça, c'est la police.
Donc déjà, il faut que ce ce versant là
fonctionne très bien pour que les pour
que les enquêtes sortent puis qu'ell
qu'elles sortent vite et qu'elles
sortent bien. Parce que une enquête mal
faite, c'est une relaxe. Ça, on l'oublie
souvent. Parfois les les faits sont là,
mais elle peut être tellement mal faite,
elle peut tellement, voyez, si vous
voulez avec des vis, enfin ou mal fait
tout simplement, c'est que on n pas
d'autre choix que de ne pas condamner.
Ça ça nous est arrivé. C'est très
frustrant d'ailleurs. Bon, donc c'est
déjà la police. C'est aussi et c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure au début euh
des organes qui ne fonctionnent pas qui
ne fonctionnent pas bien qui sont là
pour en prévention justement détecter
tous les endroits où il y aurait des
infractions. Aujourd'hui, pratiquement
la majorité des affaires sortent ce que
je disais tout à l'heure par des
articles de journaux, des investigation.
C'est pas normal. C'est pas normal que
ça sorte comme ça. Donc il faut avoir
une réflexion en amont et stratégique
sur la manière d'être moins aveugle et
d'être plus ciblé et de savoir aller
chercher la fraude là où elle est. Ça
veut dire qu'il faut il faut réorganiser
aussi la manière dont on travaille. Il
faut être beaucoup plus proactif. Euh il
faut sans doute euh renforcer le
renseignement criminel, renforcer les
offices, renforcer le rôle des parquets
parce que les parquets en fait, ils sont
aujourd'hui euh noyés dans la masse. Ça
c'est un vrai sujet. C'est je je sais
pas si on aura le temps de l'aborder,
mais la manière dont la justice
travaille est en fait catastrophique. On
est noyé par la masse et du coup, on n
pas le temps vraiment de faire des
enquêtes ciblées d'investigations avec
des moyens et cetera et cetera. Donc si
vous voulez, c'est toute une stratégie
générale. Il faut il faut pas regarder
juste un petit morceau en disant "Ah là
ponctuellement il y a eu un ordre et
tout." Ça peut arriver, ça peut arriver.
Je peux pas dire que ça n'arrive pas
mais il y a il y a plein de biais si
vous voulez qui font que votre enquête
elle peut mettre en difficulté. Il il y
a qui choisit le juge d'instruction ?
Combien de personnes on va lui mettre
pour pour travailler avec lui ? Est-ce
que la commission rogatoire elle va elle
va revenir ou jamais revenir ? Enfin
voilà, il y a il y a tous ces biais si
vous voulez mais mais il y a pas que ça.
Il y a pas que ça. C'est pas vrai. Il y
a aussi la compétence des magistrats,
c'est-à-dire former des magistrats de
haut niveau, leur donner aussi des
assistants pour travailler. Un magistrat
aujourd'hui, il est tout seul. Il faut
bien comprendre comment fonctionne un
magistrat. Les magistrats qui sont sur
ces enquêtes là souvent sont tout seuls,
pas toujours bien formés. Souvent c'est
l'expérience qui les forme et cetera et
cetera. on on a un système de RH qui est
qui est totalement à revoir là-dessus et
qui n'est pas du tout euh anodin quant
au résultat et à l'efficience de ce que
l'on cherche. Donc voilà, mais après
ponctuellement,
on est sorti quand même de de d'années
et d'années où le politique pouvait
donner des instructions évidemment
direct. C'est fini depuis Christian
Tobira. Euh le politique ne peut plus
donner des instructions euh si vous
voulez comme ça directement, mais il y a
d'autres biais. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait
euh tant qu'on sera pas sorti d'un autre
problème qui est qui est à mon avis euh
le vraiment l'étape la plus importante
qui est celle de la carrière des
magistrats qui est en grande partie aux
mains du politique et que le politique
ne veut pas lâcher, et bien évidemment
vous avez plein de moyens. D'abord euh
les mutations sont un moyen. Euh ne pas
mettre le bon magistrat au bon endroit,
ne jamais lui donner sa compétence peut
être un moyen. Euh le disciplinaire et
on l'a vu récemment peut être un moyen
de déstabiliser ou de neutraliser un
magistrat. Van Rinbec en a fait
l'expérience mais plein d'autres l'ont
fait avant lui. Euh il y a aussi des
moyens euh qui sont ce qu'on a évoqué
tout à l'heure de pas donner des moyens
pour travailler et cetera et cetera.
Donc si vous voulez euh
là tant qu'on aura on sera pas sorti de
cette ambivalence, de cette ambiguïé
complètement néfaste où les magistrats
aussi veulent peut-être parfois plaire
aux politiques parce qu'ils veulent
faire carrière parce que c'est dans les
deux sens hein, vous savez c'est pas
qu'à sens unique tout ça euh et ben on
n'ura pas un système en tout cas
transparent ni sain sur la manière
d'aborder les sujets.
Le cas du pont Moretti ça vous inspire
quoi ? Est-ce que vous pouvez nous
résumiser trivialement ce qu'on lui
reproche ? Qu'est-ce qui se passe
trivialement ? Alors bon, d'abord, c'est
pas un cas, c'est un je remets ça moi,
c'est c'est c'est un c'est un phénomène
de plus en fait. Je crois que c'est même
dans dans ce que je décrit sur un temps
plus long, plus macro, c'est peut-être
l'effet de saturation. C'est-à-dire,
vous savez, parfois on sait pas pourquoi
telle affaire va provoquer telle
réaction fait et parfois des réactions
en domino d'ailleurs qu'on ne maîtrise
pas. Euh je pense qu'il y a un effet de
saturation, c'est-à-dire que euh on
demande cette réforme institutionnelle,
elle nous a été promise par François
Hollande justement de sortir de cette
ambivalence avec le politique. Et là, on
on on a un cas très précis si vous
voulez euh de possible prise illégale,
je je reste quand même possible prise
illégale d'intérêt dans la mesure où on
a
on innocence bien entendu. Bien sûr,
bien sûr où on a quelqu'un qui justement
s'attaque au poumon de ce qui est la
lutte contre les affaires
politicofinancière, c'est-à-dire le PNF.
euh
en tant que parti puisqu'il est avocat,
il est mis euh en cause dans enfin il
est mis en cause, on fait ses fadettes
dans un dossier puisqu'on cherche dans
un dossier un corbeau qui aurait pu euh
euh qui aurait pu donner une information
donc à Nicolas Sarkozy et à son avocat
qu'ils étaient sur écoute et qu'à partir
de là, ils ont pris une autre ligne qui
est la ligne Bismut à faire qui est en
cours de jugement et dont
le jugement va arriver au mois de mars.
Le jugement, l'audience est passée, le
jugement varie et si vous voulez, lui il
est avocat, il apprend aussi que il a
été en ses fadettes ont été faites, il
est avocat, c'est tout à fait son droit.
Il est furieux, il le dit, il l'exprime
et cetera. C'est tout à fait son droit.
Il y a pas de sujet.
J'ai pas J'ai vraiment là-dessus, j'ai
j'ai aucun commentaire à faire si vous
voulez. Il est il est en droit de le
faire et il le fait et il le fait même
bruyamment puisqu'en fait il fait des
déclarations et il dépose plainte contre
le PNF. Sauf que quelques jours plus
tard, mais quelques jours plus tard, à
peine je crois à peine une semaine plus
tard, il est nommé à la responsabilité
comme garde des sauts. Donc il change
complètement de casquette. Il devient un
membre du gouvernement.
euh membre du gouvernement et sur cette
nouvelle casquette, il a autorité en
plus si vous voulez sur le parquet
national financier puisque il a une
autorité fonctionnelle et puis il a une
autorité aussi dans la mesure où c'est
lui qui peut nommer faire du
disciplinaire sur les magistrats du
parquet. Et ce qui se passe, c'est que
quand il arrive en fait donc comme garde
des saut très rapidement euh suite à un
première inspection qui avait été faite
par Nicole Boubé, donc c'était pas lui,
euh qui disait queil y avait pas de
dysfonctionnement majeur imputable à des
magistrats mais des dysfonctionnements
de gouvernance qu'on peut retrouver dans
d'autres parquets.
Il prend la décision
de refaire une enquête administrative
cette fois-ci contre trois magistrats.
Trois magistrats dont la chef du parquet
national financier contre qui il en
voulait et c'était c'était c'était pas
un secret. Et si vous voulez en
changeant de casquette comme ça euh il
c'est là où tout le monde a dit "Mais
attendez, c'est pas possible, on peut
pas à la fois être parti." Et puis une
fois qu'on est en responsabilité avec
une autorité, exercer d'une certaine
façon des représailles, je je simplifie
si vous voulez, alors qu'on a un intérêt
et en plus un intérêt qui est doublé
puisque il est aussi très proche de
l'avocat euh maître Herzog qui était
renvoyé dans le dossier qui vient d'être
jugé justement sur ses écoutes sur ses
écoutes téléphoniques. Donc si vous
voulez, il aurait dû rester d'une
neutralité totale. Ce qui ne veut pas
dire, et ça je suis très précise que il
a tort ou il a raison de critiquer.
C'est pas le sujet si vous voulez. Le
problème c'est pas le disciplinaire. Le
problème c'est que c'est lui qui ne peut
pas le faire. C'est juste ça.
C'està-dire pourquoi pas rechercher des
responsabilités. Moi, je ne connais pas
le dossier donc je j'ai rien à dire
là-dessus. et s'il y a des
responsabilités,
c'est tout à fait normal qu'elle soit
recherchée. Le problème, c'est lui.
C'est-à-dire que c'est et c'est pour ça
que euh ils ont trouvé euh une si vous
voulez une solution qui est un bricolage
juridique en réalité de dire c'est le
premier ministre du coup qui va
s'occuper du dossier. Sauf que, et c'est
ce que tout le monde
dit à ce momentlà dans ce dossier
précis, c'est que certes le premier
ministre qui est un peu un bricolage va
se retrouver en charge maintenant de
faire le disciplinaire des magistrats.
Bon euh parce que c'est une forme de
déport mais il fallait le faire avant si
vous voulez, pas après. Euh voilà. Donc
voilà le dossier qui est en cours. Voilà
le dossier qui va être examiné par la
Cour de justice de la République puisque
la commission des requêtes euh a dit que
les plaintes, certaines plaintes et
certains signalements euh étaient
recevables. Euh voilà sur quoi elle va
se pencher. Est-ce que oui euh on peut
justement euh faire ce qu'on appelle une
présomption euh de prise illégale
d'intérêt. Je sais pas si j'ai été clair
mais
c'est le sujet qui occupe aujourd'hui
voilà le garde des saut.
Comment vous expliquez que dans
certaines affaires, il y a des pièces
qui disparaissent ? Il y a des choses
comme ça qui
al elles sont perdues hein. J'ai encore
un avocat qui m'a appelé hier en me
disant que il était dans une direction
où on avait perdu son dossier. Bon ça
peut arriver. Non non mais oui oui. Non
mais je sais c'est c'est étonnant mais
alors mais
comment ça se fait alors ? Alors non
mais ça peut parfois être des des
explications relativement simples.
D'accord. Et quand ça touche à la
scientologie ou des choses comme ça ? Ah
je je sais pas sur ce dossier, c'est un
je je je vois très bien à quoi vous
faites allusion hein parce que c'est un
dossier où j'étais très jeune magistrate
si je suis internet. Mais je ne sais pas
mais c'est si vous voulez tout est
possible. En réalité, les magistrats et
la cirurgiaire sont des êtres humains
avec leur vertu et leur vie, c'est leur
turpitude et leur faiblesse et et donc
il n'est jamais impossible d'imaginer
qu'un dossier puisse disparaître pour un
intérêt. Je je ne sais pas. Alors dans
le dossier que vous citez de la
santologie, je crois que ça avait été
il y avait eu une explication il me
semble. Après, est-ce que c'est fréquent
? que je je objectivement je n'ai
je n'en ai aucune idée. Euh
moi je pense que ce qui est bon alors
voyez, je ne sais pas mais ce qui est ce
qui est surtout très ennuy
surtout la lenteur des dossiers qui
peuvent être jugés. Alors c'est une
forme de perte he perdu de vue à ce
moment-là. Voyez c'est pas tout à fait
pareil mais c'est plutôt perdu de vue.
Euh et il y a des dossiers les délais de
jugement sont absolument incroyables.
Oui, ça c'est un vrai sujet.
sujet pour tout le monde hein.
Question internet, est-ce que vous
pouvez définir ce qu'est la fraude
sociale ?
C'est la la je suis pas du tout une
spécialiste de la fraude sociale. Je je
je reconnais que je n'en ai jamais fait
d'ailleurs. Mais euh la fraude sociale,
ça va être tout ce qui euh permet
d'obtenir, si vous voulez, des avantages
sociaux euh en commençant sans doute par
une carte vitale d'ailleurs, par des
fraudes qui peuvent être des faux
documents, des usurpations d'identité,
euh
des montages, enfin, voyez, ça peut être
ça. C'est-à-dire la fraude sociale,
c'est
avoir accès à une prestation quelle
qu'elle soit qui est qui est sociale
alors qu'on n'y a pas le droit. Donc ça
c'est une fraude. Après ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir par quelle
manœuvre si vous voulez ça a été fait.
Et là il y a il y a plusieurs
possibilités. Il y a plusieurs
possibilités. Et par exemple, je pour
répondre peut-être de façon plus précise
à l'internaute, euh Charles Pratz
expliquait euh euh qu'on avait euh ils
avaient recensé beaucoup de citoyens qui
avaient plus de 128 ans. Euh donc si
vous voulez euh très clairement euh là
il y a il y a un petit sujet,
c'est-à-dire qu'on avait sans doute
changé la date de naissance et et donc
on continuait à toucher. Alors, je pense
que pour cet âge là, c'était des
allocations qui étaient plutôt de
l'ordre, enfin des de la retraite en
fait et donc personne l'administration
ne l'avait pas vu.
Question suivante, s'il vous plaît,
pourquoi les affaires de pédocriminalité
ont du mal à sortir ?
Alors, pour plein de raisons,
d'abord et une affaire récente
qui est qui est qui est laffaire qui
occupe aujourd'hui les médias, qui est
l'affaire alors avec toute la
présomption d'innocence hein évidemment
que requient cette affaire euh
même si bon tout le monde en parle comme
si c'était un voilà c'était un inceste.
l'affaire par exemple du Amel.
Pour ceux qui n'ont pas lu le livre et
familiar grand de
Camille Kouchner, on voit très bien tout
le processus dans ces affaires
qui est lié à la libération de la
parole. Il est extrêmement difficile
pour ceux qui sont victimes de parler
dans les affaires de pédocriminalité,
d'autant plus quand elles sont dans la
sphère familiale ou intime ou en tout
cas des proches et ce qui est souvent le
cas, c'est les les trois/4 des affaires
de pédo de de pédocriminalité. Alors,
pédogrammité, c'est un c'est un terme un
peu générique. On a l'impression qu'il y
a une organisation derrière et ça existe
hein. Il y a aussi des affaires de
pédogrammité qui sont importantes,
notamment sur le dark web d'ailleurs,
des choses assez à fauses mais euh et de
trafic d'enfant tout court. Mais euh la
la difficulté d'abord, c'est que souvent
les enfants sont petits donc et souvent
les agresseurs sont dans la sphère
familiale, ils ont autorité. Donc c'est
c'est quasi impossible pour eux de
libérer la parole et souvent la parole
elle se libère une fois qu'ils sont
grands ou par un/ tiers ou quand ils
sont placés ou parce que il y a d'autres
sévices et cetera et cetera. Donc déjà,
il y a une difficulté matérielle et
psychologique extrêmement importante.
Ensuite, euh euh la parole quand elle se
libère reste la parole d'un enfant qui
évidemment par rapport à la parole d'un
adulte qui souvent est pervers hein,
parce que c'est souvent quand même des
c'est quand même des actes de perversion
et donc des gens souvent intelligents et
très vite mis en difficulté et donc
c'est c'est compliqué. l'enfant, voilà,
il va il va être moins précis, tout ça.
Donc c'est c'est ce sont des sujets très
compliqués, très compliqués. Euh après
euh
pourquoi c'est c'est des sujets qui euh
euh qui ne qui ne sortent pas assez ?
Ben moi je pense parce que il y a pas
une volonté politique forte derrière de
faire en sorte c'est très récent de de
protéger les enfants et d'avoir des
spécialistes sur ces
contentieux. Pendant très longtemps, les
mineurs en fait étaient souvent
interrogés par des brigades de tout
venant si vous voulez. Donc c'est très
récent hein, c'est vraiment récent. Ça
fait quelques années qu'on a des des
brigades spécialisées pour recueillir la
parole de l'enfant euh et aussi euh pour
euh éviter qu'elle se répète. Donc
maintenant, on filme, voilà. Mais tout
ça c'est récent. Donc ça veut dire que
derrière il faut encore en faire un une
priorité
de politique pénale, pardon. et encore
15 ans.
Oui. Et puis il y a il y a un lourd euh
il y a alors là on revient sur le
culturel hein, ce que je disais tout à
l'heure aussi euh on a eu en France
quand même aussi un et on le voit très
bien alors par exemple dans dans
l'affaire du AML toute une génération
vous savez un peu post 68 de
libéralisation de des mœurs et cetera
que l'on paye qu'on que que l'on a que
l'on a eu et que l'on paye encore.
Voilà. Donc maintenant aujourd'hui, il
me semble que le mouvement, il y a une
prise de conscience et tant mieux. Il
faut voir jusqu'où ça va, mais cette
prise de conscience, elle suffit pas. Il
faut l'accompagner derrière de choses
concrètes. Et encore une fois, la
justice est très très démunie dans ses
moyens et quand je dis justice, c'est
justice police évidemment.
Question internet. La criminalité
a-t-elle augmenté avec le niveau de
pauvreté en France et dans quelle
proportion ?
Alors euh le lien criminalité pauvreté
est souvent fait. La criminalité
organisée hein la question non primité
tout courité tout cour
euh
j'ai pas de chiffre, je saurais pas
répondre à cette question. Euh
ce que ce que l'on sait c'est que la
crimité euh augmente même si euh
les formes de violence se modifient,
changent euh et ce que l'on sait c'est
que la pauvreté aussi augmente en
France. Donc euh le lien par contre euh
qui pourrait être fait entre les deux
phénomènes, il est pas évident.
il mériterait d'être analysé très
précisément. Donc je suis pas en
capacité de de faire ce lien mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que les deux les deux
mouvements augmentent. Il y a il y a une
augmentation très forte de la pauvreté
et on le sait hein, les rapports sont là
pour le dire. Euh et après les
questions, c'est qu'est-ce que c'est que
la pauvreté ? Par exemple, aujourd'hui
on peut s'alerter sur le niveau de vie
des des jeunes étudiants qui sont
parfois sur un seuil quasi de pauvreté.
Vous voyez ? Donc il faut voir aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on appelle pauvreté et
comment on le définit.
On va passer à la deuxième partie de
notre interview. On va passer Tero.
Je bois alors
alors un petit coup.
Revenons à nos moutons.
Depuis la ferméa il y a eu combien de de
blessés ? Combien de morts sur le
territoire français ?
Ah là, je suis très mauvaise dans les
chiffres.
900 blessés. Un peu plus.
Un peu plus. Non non, on est on est un
peu plus. On est on est on doit pas être
loin des 500 crois. Ouais, puisqueen
fait on a eu quand même l'attentat du
Bataclan. Euh euh je suis désolée. Alors
je suis pas très chif moi. Mais non, je
pense qu'on est beaucoup plus que ça.
Quel quel
Mais mais ça reste très faible en
réalité si on devait ramener ça au
nombre de morts sur d'autres secteurs
mais ça reste trop fort pour parce que
c'est quand même une criminalité très
particulière.
Euh quel bilan on peut avoir sur
l'action de l'État ? Est-ce que c'est un
bilan positif ? Est-ce que c'est un
bilan en demi-teinte ? Est-ce que c'est
un bilan qui brasse de la fumée, de
l'air chaud pour dire qu'on est activé
et que on essaie de faire ce qu'on peut
? Quels sont les les
armes du système judiciaire français
pour combattre ça ? Quelles sont les
capacités de faire réintégrer
ces personnes dans une vie
sociale, une vie normale ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ? Est-ce qu'on
les expulse ? Est-ce qu'on les expulse
pas ? Est-ce qu'on les libère ? Est-ce
que une fois qu'ils sont libérés,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? Est-ce que ce
problème inextricable
notre système judiciaire a les armes ?
Et est-ce que notre système judiciaire
est prêt par rapport à cette nouvelle
menace ? On a 5h là pour je répondre
parce que là vous m'avez fait un
programme de questions. Alors euh on va
je vais essayer d'être simple et rapide.
Non non non, on tomble pas dans le
simple et court donc vous prenez votre
temps.
D'accord. Euh d'abord il faut voir d'où
on part
très clairement. On a la chance en
France d'avoir un arsenal législatif
relativement extrêmement fort. Il faut
quand même le reconnaître pour quand on
est bon. il faut le dire euh puisque le
terrorisme n'est pas une inconnue pour
nous. Euh on a un arsenal législatif
depuis les années 80 qui n'a cessé de
s'amplifier, de se consolider, euh de se
conforter avec un modèle qui a été un
choix euh complètement assumé euh de la
spécialisation euh puisque nous avons
des magistrats spécialisés sur le
terrorisme en tout cas en tout cas au
parquet et à l'instruction. Euh donc
pour le parquet, donc pour les
magistrats qui poursuivent, qui font les
enquêtes avec les juges d'instruction.
Et on a pas des magistrats spécialisés,
on a des chambres spécialisées, ce qui
est pas tout à fait pareil, c'est-à-dire
des des chambres qui sont dédiées au
jugement des terroristes. Donc ça depuis
les années 80 où on a eu déjà des vagues
d'attentat, on avait déjà préparé si
vous voulez et même on avait une
doctrine, on a eu même des des
magistrats, des juges d'instruction
assez connus qui qui ont qui ont déjà
posé des très bonnes bases sur la lutte
antiterroriste. Votre question, elle est
d'actualité, j'imagine.
Où est-ce qu'on en est ? Donc on parle
pas de rien et c'est c'est c'est pas peu
de le dire. C'est pas peu de le dire par
rapport à d'autres pays. D'autant plus
que on a euh
dans dans ce départ euh des choses que
d'autres pays nous envos.
C'est notre juge d'instruction
et la blanquette de vous.
Non.
Et cette cette infraction très
intéressante, très très contestée
évidemment par les avocats qui est
l'association de malfaiteur en vue de
commettre un acte de terrorisme. Et
pourquoi on est en vié sur ces deux sur
ces deux choses ? parce que le juge de
l'instruction, tout le monde n'a pas ce
système permet permet d'aller d'avoir
des moyens d'investigation quand on
quand on veut bien lui donner les moyens
extrêmement intéressants. Et cette
qualification d'association de
malfaiteurs permet permet, ce qui est
pas le cas dans d'autres pays,
d'appréhender juste avant la commission
de l'infraction
des personnes qui voudraient commettre
un attentat. Et d'ailleurs, on on c'est
pratiquement l'infraction la plus
utilisée aujourd'hui parce que de ce que
l'on juge,
on est souvent en amont un petit peu de
l'attentat. On juge rarement
des personnes qui ont déjà commis, on en
juge hein, mais on
pensez de l'affaire Tarnac ? Laffaire
Tarnac, c'est très particulier, hein.
L'affaire Tarnac, bon, d'abord, je je
n'ai pas eu à connaître ce dossier. Euh,
on est sur la problématique. Alors, le
raccourci peut choquer, mais je vais
l'expliquer. C'est le c'est le magistrat
qui fait le terroriste. Je m'explique.
Il faut bien comprendre que en France,
la qualification qui est un enjeu
extrêmement important, la qualification
retenue choisie euh de terrorisme, elle
appartient à l'appréciation du
magistrat.
Oui, mais c'est une arme. C'est une arme
dans tous les sens. C'est-à-dire que on
peut disqualifier, on peut surqualifier,
on peut se tromper dans la
qualification, on peut avoir envie de
qualifier plus souvent du terreau un peu
moins. Bon, quand il y a des morts et
que les choses sont comme un attentat du
Pat à clan, il y a il y a pas
il y a pas beaucoup de marge de
manœuvre. sur des choses qui sont plus
en amont et qui sont plus subtiles. Euh
le magistrat a quand même une marge
d'appréciation relativement par subtil
importante. Par exemple, je prends des
exemples très important très simples.
C'était un des premiers attentats de de
cette nouvelle vague qui qui est sur
laquelle on est d'attentat terroriste.
Vous aviez il y a 4 5 ans quelqu'un qui
avait foncé avec une voiture, c'était
dans la région de Vienne, sur des
soldats en faction.
Euh
aujourd'hui, ça serait sans doute
qualifié de terrorisme parce qu'on sait
que Al-Qaïda dit il faut cibler et
cetera. les policiers prenaient
n'importe quel objet, la voiture machin.
À l'époque ça ça n'a pas été retenu en
qualification terroriste, mais euh ça a
été retenu sur une qualification de
droit commun. Donc vous voyez bien que
là selon le contexte, selon
l'appréciation, selon la subjectivité,
selon plein de choses, on peut avoir une
appréciation différente
sur la qualification. C'est exactement
la même chose sur toutes les infractions
qui sont des infractions un petit peu
plus light entre guillemets mais qui qui
peuvent être terrorisme qui sont les
infractions avec des coups de couteau.
Très compliqué ça les coups de couteau.
Est-ce qu'il a crié à l'accar ? Est-ce
que derrière
Tarnac ? C'est quoi Tarnac ? Alors
Tarnac, on est on
viendra sur les coups de côteau et la
web. Oui, mais Tardac justement a été
toute tout un toute une discussion
jusqu'à la Cour de cassation sur la
qualification terrorisme et jusqu'au
jugement où on est parti et c'est là où
je dis que derrière il peut y avoir
aussi une instrumentalisation politique
soit à la hausse ou à la baisse d'un
phénomène terroriste parce que la
qualification terroriste c'est d'abord
n'oublie jamais une infraction
non mais c'est une infraction politique.
Donc elle elle interpelle le politique,
elle s'adresse au politique. Elle est
souvent un mouvement de contestation
politique he par exemple la Corse, les
Basques, on ne sait très bien.
Jaune.
Non, on n'est pas sur du terrorisme.
Est-ce que vous voyez un jour les
politiques traiter le mouvement des
gilets jaunes comme des terroristes ?
Bah c'estàdire que
c'est déjà le cas, c'est ça ? Non,
non, non, non, non. Mais non, non, pas
du tout. C'est mais tout dépend des
modes opératoires. Tout tout dépend de
l'intention. Tout dépend. Enfin, c'est
c'est pas si simple. Voilà. Mais il est
il est il est sûr et on le sait depuis
toujours depuis tout de que sur le
terrorisme, c'est une arme aussi qui
peut qui peut permettre de désigner
l'ennemi qui est un adversaire, un
adversaire politique. Le désigner comme
terroriste, évidemment, c'est pas le
même impact que de le traiter en droit
commun. Donc, il peut toujours y avoir
une instrumentalisation dans la
qualification. Et pour répondre à à
l'affaire de Tarnac, c'est peut-être ce
qui s'est peut-être un peu passé
puisqueen fait ça a été tout le débat
euh que c'était pas du tout terrorisme
mais une infraction de droits commun.
Donc voilà. Donc quand je dis c'est le
magistrat qui fait le terrorisme, c'est
c'est ce raccourci, c'est ça et c'est
pas rien. Et c'est pas rien parce que on
peut surévaluer un phénomène ou le
sous-estimer
aussi avec cette variable, sauf sur les
grosses choses. Après donc on parle de
de quelque chose qui est déjà un
existant très fort. Maintenant, on est
sur
des modifications très importantes
aujourd'hui qui oblige obligatoirement
l'État à avoir une nouvelle stratégie.
D'abord euh l'ennemi le terrorisme est
devenu un contentieux de masse. C'est
pas rien ça. C'est-à-dire que euh là où
on avait quelques affaires qui qui
étaient qui étaient quand même des
affaires importantes pendant des années,
il y a eu des vagues quand même plus ou
moins importantes. Aujourd'hui, on a un
flux extrêmement important d'affaires
terroristes. On a un tel flux d'ailleurs
que c'est une vraie problématique pour
les jugés. Et on a des on a maintenant
des juridictions qui tournent à temps
plein que ça soit aux assises ou en
correctionnel que sur ces sujets-là.
Moi, il se trouve que dans dans ma
carrière de magistrat, j'ai j'ai été
affecté une chambre qui faisait du
terrorisme, qui était la 14e chambre et
la crimé organisé. À l'époque, j'avais
eu à connaître l'affaire du dossier de
ce qu'on appelle l'émire blanc, Olivier
Corel, les frères clins, ce qu'on
appelait le dossier Artiga,
des personnages qu'on a retrouvé
d'ailleurs très récemment pour certains
euh dans les derniers attentats
terroristes, l'attentat du 13 septembre.
C'est ça. Je vous parle de 2009, on est
en 2020. Euh,
non, pardon.
21.
Oui, 21 maintenant. Merci. Mais euh je
dis 2020 parce que ça vient d'être jugé
en 2020. Mais ce que je veux dire par
là, c'est que
à l'époque
où où j'étais magistrat dans cette
chambre,
on avait quelques affaires. C'était le
début des filières islamistes
d'ailleurs, on avait surtout du basque,
du Corse
et on en avait pas tant que ça en fait.
C'était vraiment enfin c'était pas du
tout à flux tendu. Aujourd'hui, c'est
devenu un un contentieux de masse.
Première chose. Deuxième changement et
c'est pas rien dans la stratégie c'est
que ce qui était alors je fais simple
mais une menace projetée en tout cas bon
Artigas c'était pas une menace projetée
mais qui était quand même souvent
téléguidée de l'extérieur et avec des
cellules
projeté ou importé. projeté ou importé
d'ailleurs avec des cellules d'ailleurs
qui qui ont prospéré hein pendant des
années qui étaient entre Londres, la
Belgique, le Yémen, l'Égypte, enfin on
avait à peu près toujours les mêmes
cartes. Aujourd'hui, on est confronté à
quelque chose de très différent puisque
pour prendre une terminologie un peu
classique, l'ennemi est intérieur.
C'estàd que aujourd'hui je dis pas que
n'importe qui peut être terroriste, mais
on a une masse de personnes qui sont
recensées comme sur le fichier des
personnes justement à caractère
terroriste le qui peut qui sont
potentiellement
susceptibles d'être dangereux sur notre
territoire qui est extrêmement
importante, qui est diffuse. Donc on est
plus sur des structures telles qu'on a
connu organisé mais c'est beaucoup plus
en risum éclaté et on a un phénomène
presque low cost en fait de de
terrorisme où on n pas besoin d'avoir
des moyens extrêmement importants pour
faire du terrorisme. un couteau, une
voiture,
chen
un chen. Voilà, on a aussi
ce qui est tout à fait nouveau, c'est
les réseaux sociaux avec l'apologie du
terrorisme qui est aussi un contentieux
de masse. Et on a vu progressivement
quelque chose qui est pas du tout récent
mais que l'on n'a pas ené comme les
stupes. D'ailleurs, c'est pareil euh des
endroits très spécifiques
d'endoctrinement comme les prisons,
comme les centres culturels autour de de
certaines mosquées identifiées comme des
mosquées extrêmement actives et cetera
et cetera. Donc, on a un phénomène que
l'on a que l'on a que l'on a sans doute
mal évalué de ce côté.
On a mis sous le tapis,
pardon. Oui.
Qu'on a mis sous le tapis. Non, parce
que mal qu'on a mal évolué, c'est ou
en tout cas qu'on a laissé
ça laisse planer un petit peu
d'incompétence quand même. Mais mais
c'est c'est un joli petit terre de flut
comme dirait l'autre. Mais mais
qu'on a caché, qu'on a sous-estimé,
qu'on a laissé puler
par subordnation de vote et qui s'est
transformé en énorme métastase.
Exactement.
La faute à qui ?
la faute la faute à ceux qui gouvernent
évidemment et qui sont en responsabilité
et on en fait partie les magistrats
d'une certaine façon pas pour gouverner
mais pour être en responsabilité. Euh
mais
je je sais oui, on peut on on on peut
poser la question comme ça, mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que aujourd'hui on est
dans une situation euh qui qui est
beaucoup plus grave parce que le
terrorisme n'est que la partie émergée
d'une contestation beaucoup plus large
en réalité. euh qui est qui est quasi
politique culturelle en fait de de
contestation de euh
référence à l'islam politique
bien sûr, tout à fait euh qui n'est pas
qu'une qui n'est pas qu'une
contestation, j'allais dire du pouvoir
politique, mais qui est une contestation
d'une société entière, si vous voulez,
dans dans sa manière d'être et cetera et
cetera. Et puis surtout euh ce que ce
qui est complètement extrêmement
inquiétant euh et ça c'est c'est
vraiment en tout cas visible maintenant
et peut-être pas nouveau mais en tout
cas visible, c'est les infiltrations sur
des points stratégiques. Ces points
stratégiques, c'est l'école, c'est euh
les organisations sportives, c'est la
fonction publique. La fonction publique
aujourd'hui, on a un vrai problème.
D'ailleurs, il y a un rapport très
intéressant qui a été fait qui a été
fait par deux parlementaires sur
l'infiltration dans la fonction publique
de ces réseau. Donc vous avez tout à
fait raison. En fait, ça a grossit, ça a
grossit, ça grossit parce que on s'est
attaché sans doute qu'à la partie
visible et spectaculaire et criminelle
de l'acte terroriste sans voir
l'écosystème derrière qui est le terreau
du terrorisme et qui a permis justement
aujourd'hui la situation dans laquelle
on se trouve d'un contentieux de masse,
d'un ennemi qui est maintenant pas
qu'extérieur ou projeté mais qui est
aussi intérieur avec des relais très
forts et qui fait que on s'est retrouvé
aux urgences pour revenir à ce qu'on
disait au départ, puisqu'en fait quand
euh la vague de d'attentat est revenue
en France, on était pas des armé mais on
était aux urgences. C'est-à-dire que
encore une fois, on avait pas anticipé
et on est passé en mode urgent en
faisant passer plein de lois qui qui est
une manière de surréagir en réalité
quand on est pris de panique. Voilà.
Donc ces lois, il y a eu des choses
intéressantes, d'autres moins, mais
elles ont permis en tout cas de faire
monter le débat et la difficulté qu'on a
vu depuis plusieurs années maintenant
parce que ça fait euh 5 6 ans hein qu'on
est sur ces sujets hein, le Bataclan,
tout ça, la difficulté à définir
l'ennemi parce que Pierre connaît ça
d'ailleurs connaît très bien qui est
notre ennemi. Et on voit encore
aujourd'hui même sur la dernière loi qui
est la loi sur le séparatisme, toute
l'ambivalence et toute la l'enjeu
sémantique à définir qui est l'ennemi
avec toutes les les précautions qui
s'imposent mais aussi les précautions
qui ne s'imposent pas, c'est-à-dire nous
l'acheter. Les précautions qui ne
s'imposent pas. Les précautions qui
s'imposent évidemment c'est celles de ne
pas faire d'amalgame et d'être très
clair sur les cibles.
Les chechen ne sont pas des terroristes.
Exactement. par exemple euh où tous les
musulmans ne sont pas non plus des
salafistes prêts à à être terroristes.
Mais il est aussi faux de dire il est
aussi faux de dire que justement
la communauté musulmane pourrait être
ciblé j'allais dire un espèce de pêche
gros qu'il est qui serait complètement
ridicule qu'il est aussi faux de dire
que ça n'a rien à voir avec l'islam
puisque c'est aussi de de cette
inspiration d'une vision rigoriste de
l'islam que prend sa source et sa
réflexion la l'action terroriste. Donc
les deux sont faux en fait en réité et
la question c'est de trouver l'équilibre
dans une société qui elle-même est
éruptive. On le voit très bien, les
sujets sont très compliqués, sont très
politisés et euh et ça ça c'est un vrai
enjeu pour l'activité de la police et
pour l'activité de la justice d'être
pris comme ça sur euh une une définition
peu claire de ce que l'on doit
rechercher.
Alors après, qu'est-ce qu'on a fait de
nouveau par rapport à cette nouvelle une
fois qu'on a un peu dit les nouveautés ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on a fait de nouveau ? On a
fait un parquet national antiterroriste.
On aurait on pourrait penser que c'est
un objet de communication puisqueen fait
quand les pouvoirs politiques comme ça
sont pris en dépourvu, il faut qu'ils
agissent. Donc ils font des discours
mais
ils s'agitent. C'est ça
qu'ils agissent. J'ai dit mais agir ça
peut aussi s'agiter et euh et on a dit
que voilà on allait faire une tasque
force politique. En réalité on a euh
on on a subi les conséquences euh de
mauvais choix stratégiqu sur le
renseignement puisqu'on a supprimé le
renseignement territorial qui étaient
les ex RG. C'est
Nicolas Sarkozi,
pardon.
Merci Nicolas Sarkozi. Et on s'est
aperçu ce que tout le monde sait quand
il lutte contre le terrorisme que le
terrorisme c'est trois choses. Un le
renseignement de le renseignement 3 le
renseignement.
Non mais très clairement voilà euh
des gens dans le renseignement.
Oui.
Votre mari ? Non.
Non pas du tout.
Absolument pas. Non non. Euh mais euh
à quoi ils ressemblent ces gens-là ?
Pardon ?
À quoi ils ressemblent ? Comment ils
font leur travail ? Les
les gens du renseignement. Oh bah, ils
sont ils sont comme vous et moi, ils
sont fonctionnaires souvent et ils sont
dans des services qui travaillent.
Alors, il y a les renseignements sur le
territoire et puis les renseignements
qui sont pas sur le territoire hein qui
qui sont projetés. Donc là, je je n'ai
pas de je n'ai pas de visibilité sur la
leur mode opératoire et tant mieux parce
que il vaut mieux que ça ne se sache pas
parce que sinon ça
ils ont tous des mondes connectés. Donc
maintenant, vous avez ils ont des mondes
connectés. Donc maintenant on a de la
visibilité,
c'est possible
et pas que nous. Désolé pour cette
plus sérieusement, donc en fait on s'est
aperçu que on s'était privé d'outils, si
vous voulez d'indicateurs et ça c'est on
le paye encore aujourd'hui. Et alors
très bizarrement et pour essayer euh
d'aller vite, on a fait deux choses
différentes. C'est-à-dire que on a tiré
les leçons euh des premiers attentats
sur le renseignement en disant "Ah, là
on a fait des fautes stratégiques, il
faut absolument vite se dépêcher de
recréer du renseignement territorial."
Donc ça a été la création de des
services de renseignement territoriaux,
le le SCRT et de remettre partout euh si
vous voulez des capteur, alors ça prend
du temps hein, on a pris du retard euh
pour essayer euh de comprendre ce qui se
passait et d'avoir des remontées
d'information. Et donc on a
reterritorialisé le renseignement avec
euh des résultats qui sont ceux qu'ils
sont, hein, c'est-à-dire le temps qu'il
faudra pour reterritorialiser le
renseignement. en évitant euh, je
l'espère la bureaucratie des remontées
d'informations que vous cibliez tout à
l'heure euh qui peuvent être aussi
extrêmement dommageables sur la
réactivité. Et pour la justice, on a
fait l'inverse. Et c'est là où il y a,
c'est-à-dire que euh on n' pas tiré la
leçon, à mon avis de ce qui était devenu
justement euh ce nouveau terrorisme.
Enfin, en tout cas, ces nouvelles
modalités de terror d'action terroriste.
C'est-à-dire qu' on a continué à
hypercentraliser
la réponse judiciaire et la création du
parquet national antiterroriste, c'est
un renforcement si vous voulez en terme
d'effectif, ça il y a pas de sujet hein
qui était nécessaire mais sur comme le
parquet national financier une structure
hyper centralisée, hyper spécialisée
parisienne. Aujourd'hui,
il y a un yatus, c'est-à-dire que vous
avez une volonté de recouvrir le
territoire
partout.
Alors, il y a quand même un problème
avec la gendarmerie. Je j'ouvre la
parenthèse, je la referme aussi sec
puisque la gendarmerie c'est 90 % quand
même du territoire, un peu plus et la
gendarmerie n'est pas vraiment inclus
dans ce travail. un scandale,
ce qui est un vrai scandale et ce qui ce
qui est surtout un un erreur
stratégique, un aveuglement d'autant
plus que euh
c'est la DGSI donc qui qui est chef de
guilote aujourd'hui le renseignement.
Alors au niveau
comment il s'appelle comment il
s'appelle le nouveau là le
si il est copain de de promo d'Emmanuel
Macron ? Je sais pas mais c'est
possible. Mais en en fait ce qui est sûr
c'est que il
c'est ça
peut-être. Oui, Nicolas Lerner. Tout à
fait. Mais ce qui est sûr c'est que la
gendarmerie elle
on lui passe le bonjour. Non.
Bonjour. Euh lui
Bonjour Nicolas.
Bonjour Nicolas. La gendarmerie elle
collabore évidemment
évidemment au service
ce qu'on appelle au service de
renseignement mais à la communauté de
renseignement. Voilà. Je cherchais. que
la bord pas mais pas pas en bas en haut
en fait. Et donc si vous voulez euh ça
ça c'est un vrai sujet parce qu'on
s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que les
terroristes sont aussi dans les campagne
et ils sont même très dans les
campagnes.
Service de renseignement d'ailleurs
service de renseignement à la PP euh sur
le territoire et donc ils sont partout
font du renseignement chez nous.
Ils font du renseignement chez nous. Il
on est à la barbe de nos propres
renseignements.
Exactement.
C'est magnifique non ?
Mais euh
il rentre chez nous comme dans du
beurre.
Mais nous arrêtez, vous allez tétaniser
ceux qui vous nous regardent. Mais nous
non mais ils sont polarisés sur d'autres
sujets, ils aiment bien sentir les les
caleçons des autres.
Mais nous si vous voulez la justice elle
a fait exactement le processus inverse,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle a hypercentralisé
premièrement. Donc ça déjà c'est c'est
très c'est très bizarre. Ça veut dire
qu'il n'y a pas de parallélisme et ça
c'est très important entre euh par
exemple et ça ça joue beaucoup sur la
réactivité et sur la qualité des des
procédures. Si vous avez un service de
renseignement, je dis au hasard à
Toulouse qui a du bon
anime anim
ou anime qui a du très très bon
renseignement
non pas anime.
En réalité bon il a pas l'équivalent si
vous voulez sur le plan judiciaire
puisque'en fait c'est hyper centralisé à
Paris. Alors on a créé des référents
pour dire quand même que il y aurait des
référents mais voyez on a recréé un
processus administratif et de lenteur
qui ne permet pas la réactivité. Mais
surtout plus grave à mon avis, c'est que
ce sont les gens qui sont sur le terrain
sur le terrain qui connaissent les
bassins de criminalité le mieux et c'est
toute une organisation de travail de
fluidité et si vous voulez de
circulation du renseignement parce que
le problème du renseignement c'est deux
choses. C'est une information traitée
donc vérifiée. C'est pas qu'une
information donc ça veut dire derrière
de la compétence.
Une information traitée et vérifiée. Oh
déjà c'est compliqué là.
Non mais c'est ça du renseignement. Ah
oui, il faut leur expliquer.
Non, le vrai renseignement c'est une
information traitée, vérifiée.
Ah ! Ah ! Je suis pas d'accord avec
vous. Le renseignement c'est du brut qui
doit être traité par C'est ce qu'ils
disent.
Non, le brut c'est l'information. Le
renseignement c'est ce qui sort une fois
que c'est traité. Donc c'est pas tout à
fait pareil.
On est d'accord.
Voilà. Donc l'information elle est là,
elle est traitée et elle devient du
renseignement quand elle est vérifiée et
quand elle a un intérêt. D'accord ? Et
si vous voulez, ce qui serait
intéressant, c'est que justement il y
ait une circularité, c'est-à-dire que le
renseignement, il est intéressant quand
il est partagé uniquement. Si vous vous
avez le renseignement, c'est bien, mais
si vous avez une difficulté pour le
faire remonter par la voie hiérarchique,
c'est ce qui s'appelle la
bureaucratisation. C'est ce qu'on a vu
avec les attentats du 11 septembre, vous
savez hein. Bon, je refais pas le schéma
mais c'est exactement ça.
Ah si si, il faut expliquer. C'estàd que
les différentes agence se garderaiit
leur petits précarrés pour avoir leur
petit budget pour pouvoir légitimer leur
salaire, légitimer leur position.
Résultat, les courses, ils sont pris ils
sont pris un attentat dingue.
Oui. C'estàd que tout était là, sauf que
on a méprisé ou on n pas voulu voir, on
n pas voulu faire remonter ou quand
s'est remonté, on n pas voulu comprendre
parce que il y a c'est toujours ce
problème de d'aveuglement par rapport à
ce qu'on vous fait remonter, de
déconnexion avec la réalité. C'est pas
possible, ça m'arrivera pas. Moi voilà.
Donc si vous voulez, il y a il y a il y
a tout ce renseignement euh qui qui est
maltraité pour le coup tout le long de
la remontée. Et euh et donc la question
du renseignement, c'est pas d'avoir le
renseignement, ce qui est déjà très
bien, c'est de pouvoir le partager
deuxièmement et de pouvoir l'utiliser au
bon moment. Bon, ça fait quand même pour
être efficace, c'est ça. Et donc si vous
avez le même parallélisme police justice
dont vous avez compris que la justice
n'est rien sans la police et la police
ne sert à rien sans la justice, enfin
sur le plan de l'efficacité évidemment
pour lutter contre les crimes. C'est un
binôme absolument indissociable et
fluide. Si vous avez une structure hyper
centralisée qui est le parquet national
antiterroriste et l'intelligence d'avoir
compris qu'il fallait reterritorialiser
le renseignement, obligatoirement vous
avez pas un parallélisme des formes. Or,
il me semble euh que le parti prix du
ministère de la justice de garder la
maîtrise et d'hypercentraliser
n'est pas une meilleure stratégie
adaptée. Il aurait fallu sans doute
garder une hypercentralisation.
Pourquoi pas ? Et faire une
déconcentration,
mais une vraie déconcentration avec et
c'est ce que font les Italiens. Je je
suis désolé hein, je je vous ai mis sous
le sous le sous le soleil de l'Italie
depuis le départ. On adore l'Italie
mais c'est exactement ce qu'on fait les
Italiens. Je vous fais remarquer
d'ailleurs que les Italiens dont tout le
monde dit depuis plusieurs années qui
sont euh le chemin le passage vous savez
entre la Libye et en tout cas le passage
de beaucoup de personnes susceptibles de
pouvoir être des terroristes non connu
depuis plusieurs depuis ces années aucun
attentat terroriste d'envergure. pas
parce qu'ils n'ont pas été ciblés
d'ailleurs hein et pas parce qu'ils ont
pas les conditions pour en avoir. Mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que les Italiens et
ça c'est extrêmement important ont une
organisation qu'il ne faut jamais
négliser car l'organisation c'est aussi
la clé du succès. Il suffit pas d'avoir
des lois, il suffit pas avoir des
compétences, il faut aussi avoir une
organisation intelligente adaptée à ce
qui la menace. Or eux qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont ? Ils ont des parquets et parce
qu'ils ont travaillé sur la mafia qui
qui est aussi une forme de terrorisme
d'ailleurs en partie.
Mafia a dit aussi pas de terrorisme chez
nous.
Oui, tout à fait. Mais c'est exactement
la même chose. Ils ont travaillé sur des
parquets territorialisés, c'est-à-dire
que il y a pas un parquet à Rome euh qui
traite de de du terrorisme. Il y a en
effet à Rome, j'allais dire la centrale
qui pilote la stratégie.
Et après, chaque parquet, chaque parquet
a des compétences de très haut niveau
euh pour lutter contre le terrorisme et
la mafia sur le territoire. Ce qui fait
que euh ils ont aussi fait quelque chose
que l'on n'a pas fait et que moi j'avais
suggéré dans le cadre euh de mes
activités syndicales parce que je suis
euh sollicitée pour donner notre on est
des experts quand on est dans un
syndicat de magistrats de loi ou les
propositions de loi et avec la
chancellerie, on travaille. Donc dans ce
cadre-là, on avait donné notre expertise
et on avait dit mais il faut absolument
un déconcentrer l'activité judiciaire
sur le territoire pour être au plus
proche du renseignement et au plus
proche de la connaissance de son bassin
criminel. Sachant qu'en plus le bassin
criminel est élargi puisqu'on voit que
aujourd'hui les profils ont quand même
beaucoup changé. Et deuxièmement, il
faut arrêter de traiter ce que ne font
pas les Italiens. D'un côté, le
terrorisme et de l'autre côté la crimété
organisée. Parce que euh on a vu, il y a
des porosités, il y a euh des enjeux,
tous les derniers attentats l'ont
démontré. On a du trafic de faux
papiers, on a des trafics de vo enfin on
a plein de choses qui montrent que en
fait il y a des alliances, il y a des
occurrence qui font que ces deux mondes
ne s'ignorent pas et peuvent travailler
ensemble, voir des délinquants passés de
délinquants chevronés ou petits
délinquants sur le terrorisme. Et les
Italiens, c'est exactement ce qu'ils
font. C'est-à-dire qu'en fait, ils
traitent ensemble les deux phénomènes,
pardon, pas parce qu'il les identifie,
parce qu'en fait il ils essayent de
récupérer le maximum d'informations pour
pouvoir mieux traiter le sujet. Nous, en
France, on a un problème de catégorie et
on a un problème euh si vous voulez euh
à modifier nos habitudes de travail et à
s'adapter. Ce qui fait que on est on a
fait exactement le chemin inverse. On a
hyper centralisé
avec ce parquet national antiterroriste
et et on n' pas déconcentré, on aurait
pu garder ça déconcentré sur le
territoire et on avait une facilité pour
le faire parce qu'on a déjà une
structure qui le permet qui sont les
juridictions interrégionales
spécialisées dites les GRS qui
s'occupent déjà de la criminé organisée
et de la criminalité financière. Donc on
avait déjà des magistrats qui avaient la
capacité de faire ce travail parce que
la procédure si vous voulez d'accrilité
organisé du terrorisme sont des
procédures un peu dérogatoires
si vous voulez au droits commun
beaucoup. Oui, oui. Non, non, mais oui,
tout à fait. et et ils ont déjà
l'habitude de travailler sur ces
procédures. Mais il y a cette volonté en
France d'hypercentralisation,
de garder le contrôle parce que le
terrorisme c'est aussi un enjeu
politique.
Est-ce que Est-ce que euh
comment vous expliquez que Londres
expulse c'est du moins l'Angleterre
expulse ses terroristes euh
en négociant avec les pays pratiquement
pratiquant la peine de mort ?
On les expulse chez vous mais vous ne
pratiquerez pas la peine de mort.
négocier h
sous peine de nous on coupe toute
relation internationale toutes les aides
c'est terminé donc ils ont signé ils
acceptent donc ils expulsent et nous on
fait pas
alors
on fait pas pourquoi parce que on est
petit bras parce que on a plus de
pouvoir à l'échelle internationale que
notre parole diplomatique c'est que du
vent parce que quoi
bon d'abord les anglais ont toujours été
plus pragmatiques que nous point ça
c'est culturel hein dont act ils ont une
ils Ils ont une approche très différente
euh que nous et on le voit très bien sur
la gestion
qu'il y avait sur sur Sangat Boulon tout
ça. Bon, ils sont ils sont beaucoup plus
pragmatiques
euh que nous. Euh ça c'est la première
chose. Euh deuxièmement euh
bon déjà là ils sortent du cadre de si
vous voulez euh qui qui qui est plus
light pour eux c'est peut-être plus
facile mais euh ils ont une politique de
négociation euh euh diplomatique aussi
qui qui qui est beaucoup plus importante
pour Non mais si oui
voilà qui qui est différente.
Alors pourquoi nous on le fait pas ?
Alors on peut le faire, on peut on peut
on peut le faire si si c'est votre
question sous certaines conditions. On
on a d'ailleurs une quelque chose de
très de très intéressant qui s'appelle
la libération expulsion puisque nous on
peut libérer bien avant la peine. Vous
savez on a un système d'exécution des
peines. Alors c'est pas le sujet ici
mais qui permet beaucoup de choses qui
permet de pas faire sa peine en prison
mais qui permet aussi de de sortir très
vite quand on y est. Donc euh quand on
est politique,
non, j'ai pas dit ça du tout.
Mais euh ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est que on on a la possibilité euh de
quand on a un condamné qui est étranger
euh de lui faire sa peine, de le relicat
de sa peine déjà dans son pays. Alors,
vous avez posé exactement la bonne
question. Faut-il encore que dans le
pays où on le revoit, il ne soit pas
soumis à des conditions de de torture et
que il ne risque pas la peine de mort.
Il y a il y a des pays où on pourrait le
faire, il y a des pays où on peut pas le
faire, mais il y a quand même des pays
où on pourrait le faire. Donc derrière,
il y a il y a plusieurs choses. Un, il
faut déjà tout simplement appliquer
cette possibilité que l'on ne fait pas.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi, on ne la fait
pas assez. Deux, il faut que derrière il
y a une volonté politique avec en effet
une activité diplomatique. Il faut le
faire. C'est extrêmement important. Euh
euh ce qui a été rappelé et c'est tous
les signaux d'alerte qui sont
aujourd'hui tirés, c'est de dire
attention, on va avoir énormément de de
personnes extrêmement dangereuses
d'abord qui vont sortir qui vont fait
les sortant de prison.
Après, il y a euh et ça je sais parce
que je les ai prononcé énormément
l'interdiction définitive du territoire
qui peut être prononcée pour ces profils
là. Faut-il encore faut-il encore qu'on
soit cohérent sur l'ensemble du qu'on
puisse savoir ce qui rentre et ce qui
sort de notre pays.
Pardon ?
Ou savoir ce qui rentre et ce qui sort
dans notre pays.
Oui. Mais pourquoi parfois on ne peut
pas le faire ? Quels sont les obstacles
? Et c'est c'est c'est
triste mais c'est comme ça. Par exemple,
si la personne
est papa parce qu' maintenant il peut
aussi
c'est une façon de se fixer sur le
territoire d'ailleurs.
Exactement.
à ce moment-là, s'il est avec un enfant
d'un certain âge, c'està dire de
rembasâge et cetera, c'est un obstacle,
ça peut être des obstacle. Voilà, il y a
il y a tout plein de possibilités sur le
droit, la vie familiale et cetera. Donc
il faut absolument absolument si on va
être cohérent par rapport à la fois à la
menace que l'on dénonce et au vrais
dangers euh si vous voulez euh que ces
personnes peuvent faire courir sur le
territoire, il faut absolument revoir à
mon avis euh ces circulaires ou en tout
cas être beaucoup plus rigoureux sur le
contrôle d'attribution de la paternité
ou de reconnaissance de paternité sur
lequel parfois on n'est pas extrêmement
rigoureux. Et puis surtout euh il faut
que derrière il y ait une vraie volonté
politique euh d'expulser les gens une
fois qu'ils sont sorti. Bon, maintenant
ça vient, on le fait, il faut pas dire
qu'on ne le fait pas, mais on est un
pays qui permet en effet de détourner ou
de contourner des décisions du Mais
encore une fois, la reconduite à la
frontière
n'a aucun intérêt quasiment dans la
mesure où nos frontières sont poreuses.
La reconduite à la frontière, c'est quoi
pratiquement ? c'est je vous raccompagne
à la frontière, je vous laisse à la
frontière, je vous remercie d'aller de
l'autre côté et de ne pas revenir. Mais
rien n'empêche la personne de revenir.
Si vous avez pas une interdiction
temporaire ou définitive du territoire,
euh vous passez la frontière et vous
revenez. Vous vous savez très bien qu'on
est dans un espace alors un espace
Shangun qui permet de rentrer et de
sortir relativement facilement. Alors,
il faut quand même savoir qu'en ce
moment euh c'est plus c'est moins le cas
et en partie peut-être grâce au Covid,
ça sera encore moins. Mais euh voilà,
donc c'est tout notre système si vous
voulez qu'il faut repenser euh par
rapport à à ces nouvelles menaces.
Est-ce qu'on a le temps ? Est-ce qu'on a
le temps ?
Mais bien sûr qu'on a de toute façon, il
faut le faire. C'est la question c'est
pas est-ce qu'on a le temps ? C'est il
faut prendre le temps de le faire parce
que la menace elle s'est installée pour
un longtemps.
Pourquoi il y a pas d'attentat islamiste
en Corse ? Il y a de la concurrence.
Il y a de la concurrence déjà. Euh
je je pense que la Corse Oui, justement
c'est c'est il y a déjà un contrôle du
territoire qui est fort. Donc on on
les Corses contrôlent leur territoire.
Oui, les Corses contrôlent leur
territoire en partie. Euh après, ça
tient sans doute au profil aussi des
personnes. Euh la Corse a déjà euh son
propre, j'allais dire euh
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quand il y a
des qu'est-ce qui s'est passé quand il y
a des Corses qui se sont fait un peu
ennuyer par des un peu euh radicalisés ?
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans les 10
minutes ? Euh
vous parlez des affaires qui sont c'est
qui sont qui datent d' 3 ans sur les
plages là, c'est ça ?
C'est ça.
Bah les Corses sont sorties et ont
expliqué que ça leur plaisait pas. Ils
ont dit "Toi, on sait où tu habites."
Oui. Oui. Mais alors après,
je pense que bon, on en pense ce qu'on
veut.
Je je je pense que c'est pas un mode
normal non plus si vous voulez pour un
état qui qui doit être souverain sur son
territoire en réalité et où la loi doit
s'appliquer telle que il pense qu'elle
doit s'appliquer que justement on est
des phénomènes et c'est c'est le c'est
le risque d'ailleurs quand un état est
défaillant sur sa sécurité ou sur sa
justice c'est qu'on ait des phénomènes
comme ça de population qui qui se
rendent justice ou qui fassent leur
propre sécurité. Ça existe dans d'autres
pays hein, vous le savez. Et et donc
c'est quoi ? C'est un signal de
faiblesse de l'État en réalité quand on
en arrive là.
Je j'ouvre une parenthèse là. Récemment
en Russie, il y a il y a des il y a un
mec qui a attrapé un pédophile la main
dans le sac en train de torturer des
gamins
et il a un peu réagi à la russe. Il a
neutralisé le gars, il lui il lui a mis
4 5 6 7 bourpif et et le pédophile en
question est mort en arrivant à
l'hôpital. Hm hm.
Le mec qui a cogné le pédophile a pris 8
ans de tôle.
C'est normal, c'est pas normal.
Non, mais votre question, elle est un
peu enfin la répulste hein. C'est
Non, mais la réponse, elle est
impossible pour moi parce que d'abord
un, je connais pas du tout le dossier
donc je voilà. Euh de je connais pas du
tout la législation russe ni leur
pratique. Voilà. Je je je peux pas
répondre à
on va faire on va on va on va on va
imaginez-vous
on est en plein confinement on entend
des cris de gamin. Moi je monte je fais
2 m je fais 115 kg j'attrape le mec je
le plie en quat
oui
le mec meurt en allant à l'hôpital.
Oui. Bah vous serez poursuivi.
Pourquoi ?
Bah pour pour alors ça dépend de la
manière dont dont vous l'avez fait. si
vous l'avez fait volontairement pour le
tuer ou non, mais vous vous serez
poursuivi euh pour coup et blessure
ayant entraîné la mort de manière
involontaire ou volontaire si vous avez
vraiment la volonté de ça tout dépend de
la manière dont c'est fait.
Combien je risque ?
Bah déjà vous risquez euh plus bah vous
risquez plusieurs années plus ça dépend
si c'est sur l'involontaire ou sur le
volontaire en réalité. C'est surtout ça
qui fait la différence si vous voulez.
Donc
deuxème cas de figure,
on se balade dans la rue, on est tous
formés ici au manimement des armes et au
sport de combat. On voit un terroriste
arriver qui commence à à shooter
partout.
On le neutralise, on le démonte, on le
tue. On risque quelque chose ou pas ?
Mais encore une fois, si vous voulez,
c'est des exemples très compliqués parce
que tout dépend du contexte et de la
manière. Si vous êtes dans dans le cas
d'une légitime,
je le désarme.
Non, mais s'il est armé, que vous êtes
dans le cas d'une légitime défense et
euh voilà. Ah après euh
c'est toute une question de
proportionnalité. En réalité,
l'appréciation, si vous voulez euh de la
légitime défense, elle est dans la
proportionnalité. C'est-à-dire que si
vous tuez quelqu'un qui
n'est pas armé ou qui ne risque pas de
vous tuer, oui, c'est ça la
proportionnalité. Vous n'êtes plus dans
le casre d'une légitime défense.
Donc si je le désarme et que je le bute,
j'ai pas le droit.
Non.
Merde ! Alors,
mais encore c'est des cas trop enfin
c'est c'est très difficile de répondre à
votre question parce que c'est
mais non, il d'ailleurs il vaut toujours
mieux éviter de tuer quelqu'un si j'ai
un conseil à vous donner.
Voilà, mais bon, c'est c'est vos cas
sont difficiles comme ça à répondre.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez du cas Julien
Assange ?
Alors, on va on va passer du coque àan.
Bienvenue. Voulez un peu de sauce avec
pardon.
Vous voulez un peu de sauce avec ?
Non, non, non. Euh du cas de Julien
Assange. Euh
est-ce que la votre question c'est
est-ce que la France aurait dû lui
donner euh
la possibilité de venir se réfugier chez
nous ?
C'estàd le c'est ça l'asile ou de
s'occuper de son son gamin ou non ?
Parce que c'est votre question
précisément c'est quoi
le fait qu'il soit dans une prison pas
chauffée depuis des années que
humainement parlant les droits de
l'homme bafoué
et que la France la France n'a plus que
est devenue une puissance de moyenne
impuissance et et que la France marche
en canard devant les États-Unis. Bah le
problème de Julien, c'est que c'est
devenu un enjeu diplomatique en réalité
ou géopolitique, enfin ça dépend comment
on se situe, mais euh voilà. Donc
la ce que vous décrivez comme être comme
des des conditions de détention qui sont
absolument pas du tout normales et
inacceptable passe du coup au second
niveau parce que son son dossier est
devenu emblématique. Donc est-ce que oui
ou non on veut rentrer en conflit direct
ou indirect avec la puissance qui est
les États-Unis ? C'est ça qui se joue
aujourd'hui. Mais si vous me posez la
question sur est-ce que il devrait être
détenu dans des d'autres conditions, ma
réponse évidemment oui. Est-ce que il
pour il devrait pouvoir bénéficier de
l'asile politique ? Mais
personnellement, je pense que oui.
Voilà. Mais ma question enfin ma réponse
est totalement personnelle.
Votre père il juge
pas du tout.
C'est trompé le monsieur.
Non, il est médecin. Voilà. Revenons,
revenons à nos moutons.
Les terroristes qui sortent de prison,
la contreradicalisation, est-ce que vous
avez des pistes ?
Alors, les terroristes qui sortent de
prison euh aujourd'hui euh tous les
essais et il faut le faire d'ailleurs
euh et on en a fait beaucoup. On peut
pas dire qu'on a rien fait d'ailleurs,
ça serait faux. Est-ce qu'on a bien fait
? C'est ça la vraie question. Mais on n
pas rien fait. Non, on n pas rien fait.
On a peut-être pas toujours bien réagi,
mais on n pas rien fait. La vraie
question, c'est est-ce que euh vous
pouvez déprogrammer quelqu'un ? Parce
que c'est ça été he la déradicalisation.
Est-ce que vous pouvez déprogrammer
quelqu'un sur ses convictions intimes
extrêmement fortes ? Euh voilà. Est-ce
que moi, si demain je vous demande euh
de penser complètement différemment de
ce que vous pensez parce que je vous dis
qu'il faut le faire et que c'est bien et
que si vous le faites pas, vous allez en
prison. Euh voilà, c'est si vous allez
me dire vous allez me dire non
normalement et puis si vous me dites
oui, ça peut être simplement pour sortir
mais vous allez pas changer. Donc c'est
ça en fait l'enjeu en fait. La
déradicalisation elle marche en tout cas
ce qu'on a essayé de faire sur des gens
qui sont pas vraiment radicalisés.
C'est-à-dire que elle marche sur des
gens qui sont tout fraîchement si vous
voulez influencés
sur des théories, sur la propagande, sur
des fakes news, tel qu'on a pu le voir
sur ces mouvements de jeunes qui sont
partis très vite, vous savez, qui ont
regardé quelques vidéos, on leur a fait
croire que on tuait des enfants, qui
faisaient de l'humanitaire. Voilà, c'est
une c'est en fait c'est pas vraiment
d'ailleurs une radicalisation, mais si
vous voulez c'est une imprénation assez
superficielle mais assez forte quand
même pour pouvoir euh les faire partir
ou s'engager mais euh qui est
récupérable qui est récupérable d'autant
plus quand on est sur des profils
d'adolescents où on est quand même voyez
très influençable et tout
mais sur des gens qui sont vraiment
radicalisés et qui sont moi je ne crois
pas un instant qu'on puisse
déradicaliser quelqu'un contre sa
volonté ou si lui-même n'a pas fait son
propre chemin et qu'il le veut. Non, je
n'y crois pas.
On fait quoi ? Un Guantanamo à la
française ? On rétablit le bagne. On
fait quoi ?
Non non, en fait on évite que les
On vous son impuissance.
Non moi je pense
on construit des murs.
Non je pense que la première chose qu'il
faut faire c'est
on garde la poudre au sec,
c'est d'éviter que les gens se
radicalisent. Or là, on est là, on a des
marges de manœuvre très clairement parce
que une fois que c'est fait, vous savez,
c'est comme les c'est comme les
phénomènes sectaires d'ailleurs d'une
certaine façon ce qu'il faut c'est comme
tomber dans la drogue. Ce qu'il faut
c'est la prévention. Non, non, mais
c'est c'est mettre en tout cas le
maximum pour éviter déjà que ça arrive.
Or, c'est là, franchement, on a des
marges de manœuvre que ça soit dans la
jeunesse, que ça soit sur la
communication, que ça soit sur les
réseaux sociaux, que ça soit sur le
contrôle de nos frontières, que ça soit
sur le contrôle, si vous voulez ce qu'on
commence à faire tout doucement, des
écoles qui sont des écoles d'embrégement
ou sur certaines mosquées qui font de la
propagande, clairement, si vous voulez,
[Musique]
extrêmement radical. euh qui qui prépare
d'ailleurs le terrain, que ça soit sur
les clubs de sport sur lequels on a
fermé les yeux, que ça soit sur certains
territoires dont on sait très bien qui
sont à la fois à la main de de de la
Crinité organisée, mais aussi de gens
qui imposent un mode de vie pour parler
clairement la charia, mais là on a des
marges de manœuvre qui sont extrêmement
importantes encore.
On coupe les relations diplomatiques
avec l'Arabie Saoudite.
Mais ça c'est autre chose. Ça ça rien à
voir si vous voulez. Moi, je parle Non,
non, non. Provoque.
Oui, j'ai bien compris.
C'est gratuit.
Oui, c'est gratuit.
Parce que en Arabie Saoudite quand même
euh ils ont une façon de déradicaliser
les gens qui est très efficace, hein.
Oui. Non, mais je je enfin ma ma réponse
est peut-être pas satisfaisante, mais je
pense que vraiment la première chose
qu'il faut faire, c'est éviter la
contamination. Ça c'est clair et net. Or
là, on a pris beaucoup beaucoup de
retard à l'allumage et on a on voit et
ce retard, on l'a vu parce que déjà, on
avait du mal à définir ce que l'on
cherchait. On avait du mal à définir où
cela se trouvait. On avait du mal à à
comprendre le phénomène et je pense
qu'on a encore beaucoup de mal à
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer.
On arrive à la fin de notre interview.
J'ai l'impression qu'on faisait que
commencer.
Euh, est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
nous conseiller ?
Trois livres à nous conseiller ? Ben
oui. Alors, un livre que j'adore qui est
La part du héros de de
d'une jeune femme qui s'appelle Marco
Longo qui est magnifique parce que elle
revisite tous les mythes les mythes donc
de Liliade et elle montre comment on
peut tous être appelés justement à
reprendre sa vie en main et
avoir ce dépassement. ce qu'elle appelle
la méta d'ailleurs. Euh c'est un très
beau livre. Je pense que relire comme ça
de façon moderne ces mythes fondateurs
sont très intéressant pour ces nouvelles
générations qui parfois savent plus trop
où aller.
Après, je suis une fan de Anna Harte,
donc je je je dirais toujours, il faut
il faut même lire tous les livres de
Anna Rein surtout la crise de la culture
en ce moment qui me semble un livre
extrêmement intéressant. Et puis euh
c'est c'est difficile. J'aime beaucoup
je je je lis j'aime beaucoup Henry Labor
aussi. Euh je trouve que voilà euh euh
il peut y
l'éloge de la fuite est un beau livre.
Je trouve aussi assez intéressant. Après
euh c'est c'est vous me prenez un petit
peu au dépourvu.
Fall regarder plus de vidéos parce que
c'est la dernière question qu'on pose
tout le temps.
D'accord.
C'est quoi votre vidéo préférée sur
Syerview ?
Alors euh j'en ai deux, je peux le dire.
Euh j'aime beaucoup Gael Girot, beaucoup
cette idée des biens en commun, cette
réflexion sur les biens en commun et
puis sur l'économie aussi en général et
la crise systémique qui nous attend. Euh
et puis j'ai j'ai adoré votre vidéo de
sur la transhumance à les con euh
transhumance suicidaire.
Ouais, j'ai adoré parce que j'ai trouvé
que c'était à la fois d'une intelligence
et d'une humilité. Peut-être que c'est
ça va toujours ensemble d'ailleurs euh
que c'était euh à la fois visionnaire et
plein de maturité. Euh en tout cas, j'ai
ça me donne envie d'aller voir le film
que je n'ai pas je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
encore vu et j'ai trouvé euh voilà la
personnalité extraordinaire. euh
oui, très libre en fait, très libre dans
dans sa pensée et puis surtout euh
euh je pense qu'il là où il a raison,
c'est c'est de d'arrimer toute notre
réflexion sur l'éducation. Euh je pense
que c'est un point de départ et c'est là
je rejoins Narinhe l'éducation, la crise
de la culture et cetera euh qui me
semble la chose la plus importante et
nous on le voit parce que quand on est
magistrat
en fait ce qu' ce qu'on récupère souvent
dans nos tribunaux c'est justement tout
ce chemin raté dans l'éducation.
Et qu'est-ce que ça fait de se retrouver
à la croisée des chemins ou à
l'articulation de toute la lie de notre
monde ?
Qu'est-ce que ça fait ? Euh bon, je
pense que d'abord ça ça vous ça vous
fortifie, ça vous permet de relativiser
vos propres petits mots, ça c'est sûr.
Euh c'est un chemin d'humilité, hein.
C'est un chemin d'humilité parce que
parce que d'abord
on est confronté quand même au tragique
en permanence. Euh c'est une expérience,
moi je trouve humaine euh
exceptionnelle si justement on on a ce
chemin d'humidité et on a cette distance
euh qui permet de juger sans juger. Je
m'explique.
Non mais ce que je veux dire c'est c'est
très difficile. C'est-à-dire que c'est à
la fois euh on est là pour juger et à la
fois ça nous renvoie chacun à à nos
faiblesses aussi en partie évidemment.
Et euh et c'est c'est ce ce dialogue
aussi qui qui est intéressant,
c'estàdire que juger c'est pas une
mécanique hein comme ça qui tombe chaque
fois c'est une remise en question, c'est
une recherche. Faut-il encore avoir le
temps pour ça ? Faut-il encore avoir les
moyens pour ça ? Faut-il avoir des des
bonnes conditions et une bonne formation
? Et voilà, on est c'est un très beau
pays, c'est un très beau pardon métier
quand on a les moyens de l'exercer dans
des bonnes conditions.
Est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Oui. Que
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les choses
peuvent changer, voilà. Et que
l'engagement euh l'engagement est
quelque chose de de d'essentiel et que
et que il y a pas de fatalité dans ce
qui nous arrive. Béatrice Bruger, merci.
Merci.
[Musique]